the following is a conversation with dan
carlin
host of hardcore history and common
sense
podcasts to me hardcore history
is one of if not the greatest podcast
ever made dan and joe rogan are probably
the two main people who got me
to fall in love with the medium of
podcasting as a fan
and eventually as a podcaster myself
meeting dan was surreal to me
he was not just a mere human like the
rest of us since his voice
has been a guide through some of the
darkest moments of human history for me
meeting him was like meeting genghis
khan stalin
hitler alexander the great and all of
the most powerful leaders in history all
at once
in a crappy hotel room in the middle of
oregon
it turns out that he is in fact just the
human
and truly one of the good ones this was
a pleasure
and an honor for me quick mention of
each sponsor
followed by some thoughts related to the
episode
first is athletic greens the all-in-one
drink that i start every day with to
cover
all my nutritional bases second is
simplisafe
a home security company i use to monitor
and protect my apartment
third is magic spoon low carb keto
friendly cereal
that i think is delicious and finally
cash app
the app i use to send money to friends
for food and drinks
please check out these sponsors in the
description to get a discount and to
support
this podcast as a side note let me say
that i think
we're living through one of the most
challenging moments in american history
to me the way out is through reason and
love
both require a deep understanding of
human nature and of human history
this conversation is about both i am
perhaps hopelessly optimistic about our
future
but if indeed we stand at the precipice
of the great filter
watching our world consumed by fire
think of this little podcast
conversation
as the appetizer to the final meal
before
the apocalypse if you enjoy this thing
subscribe on youtube review 5 stars
nappa podcast
follow on spotify support it on patreon
or connect with me on twitter
at lex friedman and now finally
here's my conversation with the great
dan
carlin let's start with the highest
philosophical question
do you think human beings are
fundamentally good or
are all of us capable of both good and
evil
and it's the environment that molds how
we
uh the trajectory that we take through
life how do we define
evil evil seems to be a situational eye
of the beholder kind of question
so if we define evil maybe i can get a
better idea of
and and that could be a whole show
couldn't defining evil
but when we say evil what do we mean
that's a slippery one but i think
there's some way in which your existence
your presence in the world leads to
pain and suffering and destruction for
many others
in the rest of the world so you you
steal the resources
and you use them to create more
suffering than there was before
in the world so i suppose it's somehow
deeply connected to this
other slippery word which is suffering
as you
create suffering in the world you bring
suffering to the world
but here's the problem i think with it
because i i fully see where you're going
with that
and i understand it the problem is is
the question of
the reason for inflicting suffering so
sometimes
one might inflict suffering upon one
group of individuals
in order to maximize a lack of suffering
with another group of individuals or one
who might not be considered evil at all
might make the rational
seemingly rational choice of inflicting
pain and suffering on a smaller
group of people in order to maximize the
opposite of that for a larger group of
people
yeah that's one of the dark things about
i've spoken and read the work of stephen
codkin i'm not sure if you're familiar
with the historian
and he's basically a stalin a joseph
stalin scholar
and one of the things i realized i'm not
sure where to put hitler
but with stalin it really seems that
he was sane and he thought he was doing
good for the world
he i i really believe from everything
i've read about stalin
that he believed that communism
is good for the world and if you have to
kill a few people along the way if it's
like you said the small groups if you
have to
sort of remove the people that stand in
the way of this utopian system
of communism then that's actually good
for the world and it didn't seem
to me that he could even consider the
possibility that he was evil
he really thought he was doing good for
the world and that stuck with me because
he's one of the most
is to our definition of evil he seems to
have brought more evil onto this world
than almost any human in history
and i don't know what to do with that
well
i'm fascinated with the concept so
fascinated by it that the very first
hardcore history show we ever did which
was a full
15 or 16 minutes um was called alexander
versus hitler
and the entire question about it was
the motivations right so if you go to a
court of law because you killed somebody
one of the things they're going to
consider is why did you kill them
right and if you killed somebody for
example in self-defense
you're going to be treated differently
than if you malicious kill kill somebody
maliciously to take their wallet
right and in the show we we wondered
because you know i don't really make uh
pronouncements but we wondered about
uh if you believe hitler's writings for
example mein kampf
uh which you know is written by a guy
who's a political figure who wants to
get
so i mean it's about as as believable as
any other political tract would be
but in his mind the things that he said
that he had to do
were designed to for the betterment of
the german people right
whereas alexander the great once again
this is somebody from more than 2000
years ago so
with lots of propaganda in the
intervening years right but one of the
the views of alexander the great is that
the reason he did what he did was
to for lack of a better word write his
name in a more permanent graffiti on the
pages of history right in other words to
glorify himself
and if that's the case does that make
alexander a worse person than hitler
because
hitler thought he was doing good whereas
alexander if you believe the
interpretation was simply trying to
exalt alexander
so the the motivations of the people
doing these things it seems to me
matter i don't think you can just sit
there and go the only thing that matters
is the end result because that might
have been an unintentional byproduct
uh in which case that person had you
been able to show them
the future might have changed what they
were doing so were they evil or
misguided or wrong or made the wrong you
know
so and i hate to do that because there's
certain people like hitler that i don't
feel deserve the benefit of the doubt
uh at the same time if you're fascinated
by the concept of evil
and you delve into it deeply enough
you're going to want to understand
why these evil people did what they did
and sometimes
it can confuse the hell out of you you
know who wants to sit there and try to
see things from hitler's point of view
to get a better understanding and sort
of commiserate with
so um but in fact obviously first
history show i'm fascinated with the
concept
so do you think it's possible if we put
ourselves in the mindset of some of the
people that have
led created so much suffering in the
world
that all of them had their motivations
were
had good intentions underlying them no
i don't i mean simply because there's so
many i mean the law of averages would
would suggest that that's not true i
guess it is pure evil
possible meaning you uh again it's
slippery but
you the suffering is the goal
suffering intentional suffering yeah yes
i think that
and i think that there's historical
figures that that that one could point
and but that gets to the deeper question
of are these people saying
uh do they have something wrong with
them are they twisted from something in
their youth
um you know i mean
these are the kinds of things where you
start to delve into the psychological
makeup of these people
in other words is anybody born evil and
i actually believe that some people are
i think the dna can get scrambled up in
ways i think the question of evil is
important too because i think it's an
eye of the beholder thing i mean if
hitler for example
had been successful and we were today
on the sixth or seventh leader of the
third reich since
i think his entire history would be
viewed through a different lens because
that's the way we do things
right genghis khan looks different to
the mongolians than he does to the
residents of baghdad right
um and i think so so an eye of the
beholder question i think comes into all
these sorts of things as you said it's a
very slippery question
where do you put as somebody who's
fascinated by military history
where do you put violence as uh
as in terms of the human condition is it
core to being human or is it just
a little uh tool that we use every once
in a while
so i'm going to respond to your question
with a question what do you
see the difference being between
violence and force
let me go farther i'm not sure that
violence is something that we have to
put up with as human beings forever that
we must resign ourselves to violence
forever but i have a much harder time
seeing us able to abolish force
and i there's going to be some ground
where if those two things are not the
same and i don't know that maybe they
are
where there's certainly some crossover
and the re i think
force you know you're an engineer you'll
understand this better than i but think
about it as a physical law
if you can't stop something from moving
in a certain direction without pushing
back
in that same direction i'm not i'm not
sure
that you can have a society or a
civilization
without the ability to use a counter
force
when things are going wrong whether it's
on an individual level right
a person attacks another person so you
step in to save that person
um or on uh you know even at the highest
levels of politics or anything else a
counter force to stop the
uh inertia or the impetus of of of
another movement so i think
that force is is a simple almost law of
physics
in human interaction especially at the
civilizational level i think
civilization requires a certain amount
of if not violence than force
so um and again they've talked i mean it
goes back into
saint augustine all kinds of christian
beliefs about the the proper use
of force and people have have
philosophically tried to decide between
can you have a sort of an ahinsa uh
buddhist sort of we you know
we would be non-violent toward
everything and exert no force or
or there's a reason to have force in
order to create the space for good
uh i think force is inevitable now
we can talk and and i've not come up to
the conclusion myself uh if there is a
distinction to be made between force and
violence i mean is
is um is a non-violent force enough or
is
violence when done for the cause of good
a different thing than violence done
either for the cause of evil as you
would say or
simply for random reasons i mean we
humans lack control sometimes we can be
violent
for no apparent reason or goal um and
that's i mean
you look at the criminal justice system
alone and the way we
we interact with people who are acting
out in ways that we as a society have
decided
is intolerable can you deal with that
without force and at some level violence
i don't know can you maintain
peacefulness without force i don't know
just to uh be a little bit more specific
about the idea of force
do you put force as general enough
to include force in the space of ideas
so you mentioned buddhism or
religion or just twitter
i can think of no things farther apart
than that okay
is uh the battles we do in the space of
ideas
of um you know the great debates
throughout history
do you put force into that or do you
in this conversation are we trying to
right now keep it to just physical force
in saying that you you have an intuition
that force might be with us
much longer than violence i think
the two bleed together so um
take because it's it's always it's
always my go-to example i'm afraid and
i'm sure that the listeners all hate it
but take
take germany during uh the 1920s early
1930s before the nazis came to power
and they were always involved in some
level of force you know beating up in
the streets or whatever it might be but
think about it more like
an intellectual discussion until a
certain point
um is that it would be difficult i
imagine to keep
the intellectual counterforce of ideas
from at some point degenerating into
something that's more
um coercion um counterforce if we want
to use the phrases we were just talking
about
so i think the two are are intimately
connected i mean
actions follow thought right and at a
certain point
i think especially when when one is not
achieving
the goals that they want to achieve
through uh peaceful
discussion or argumentation or um trying
to convince the other side
that sometimes the next level of
operations is something a little bit
more physically
uh imposing if that makes sense we go
from the intellectual to the physical
yeah so it too easily spills over into
violence
yes and one leads to the other often so
you kind of implied uh
perhaps a hopeful message but let me ask
in the form of a question
do you think we'll always have war
i think it goes to the force question
too so for example
um what do you do i mean we're
let's let's play with nation states now
although i don't know that nation states
uh
are something we should think of as a
permanent constitution forever
um but how is one nation state supposed
to prevent another nation state
from acting in ways that it would see as
either detrimental to the global
community or detrimental to the interest
of their own nation-state um you know
and i i think
i think we've had this question of
going back to ancient times but
certainly in the 20th century this has
come up quite a bit i mean
the whole second world war argument
sometimes revolves around the idea of
what the proper counterforce should be
uh can you create an entity a league of
nations a united nations
uh a one world entity maybe even that
that
alleviates the need for counterforce
involving mass violence and armies and
navies and those things
uh i think that's an open discussion
we're still having
it's good to think through that because
um
having us like a united nations there's
usually a centralized control so there's
humans at the top
there's committees and uh usually like
leaders emerge a singular figures that
then can become corrupted by power and
it's just a really important
it feels like a really important thought
experiment and something to
really rigorously think through how can
you construct
systems of government that
are stable enough to push us towards
less and less war
and less and less unstable
and another tough war which is unfair
of application of force you know it's
that's really at the core of the
question that we're trying to figure out
as humans
as our weapons get better and better and
better destroying ourselves
it feels like it's important to think
about how we minimize
the over application or unfair
application of force
there's other elements that come into
play too you and i are discussing this
at the very high intellectual level of
things but there is also a tail wagging
the dog element to this so think of a
society of
warriors a tribal society from a long
time ago
how much do the fact that you have
warriors in your society
and that their reason for existing what
they take pride in what they train for
um what their status in their own
civilization how much does that itself
drive the responses of that society
right um
how much do you need war to legitimize
warriors
um you know that's the old argument that
you get to and we've had this in the
20th century too that
that the creation of arms and armies
creates
a an incentive to use them right and and
that they themselves can drive that
incentive as as a justification for
their reasons for existence you know
um that's where we start to talk about
the interactivity of all these different
elements of society upon one another
so when we talk about you know
governments and war we need to take into
account
the various things those governments
have put into place in terms of systems
and armies and things like that
to to protect themselves right for
reasons we can all understand
but they exert a force on your your
range of choices
don't they it's true you're making me
realize that
uh in my upbringing and i think i'm
bringing of many
warriors are heroes you know to me
i don't know where that feeling comes
from but to sort of
uh die fighting
is uh it's an honorable way to die
it feels like that i've always had a
problem with this because as a person
interested in military history
the distinction is important um and i
try to make it at different levels
so at base level the the people who are
out there
on the front lines doing the fighting uh
to me
those people can be compared with police
officers and firemen and people the
fire persons um but but i mean
people that are are um involved in
an ethical uh attempt to perform a task
which ultimately uh one can see in many
situations as being
a savings sort of task right or or if
nothing else a self-sacrifice for what
they see is the greater good now
i draw a distinction between the
individuals and the entity that they're
a part of a military
and i certainly draw a distinction
between the military and then the entire
for lack of a better word
military-industrial complex that that
service is a part of i feel a lot less
moral attachment to uh to those upper
echelons than i do the people on the
ground the people on the ground could be
any of us and have been in a lot of
you know we have a very professional uh
sort of military now where it's a very
uh a subset of the population but in
other periods of time
we've had conscription and drafts and
and it hasn't been a subset of the
population it's been the population
right
and so it is the society oftentimes
going to war and i make a distinction
between
those warriors and the entities either
in the system that they're part of the
military or the people
that control the military at the highest
political levels i feel um
a lot less moral attachment to them and
i have
i'm much harsher about how i feel about
them i do not
consider the military itself to be
heroic and i do not consider the
military-industrial complex to be heroic
i do think that is a tail wagging the
dog situation
i do think that draws us into looking at
um
military endeavors as a solution to the
problem
much more quickly than we otherwise
might and to be honest to tie it all
together i actually look at
the victims of this as the soldiers we
were talking about i mean if you
if you set a fire to send firemen
into to fight um then i feel bad for the
firemen i feel like you've abused the
trust that you give those people right
so when
when people talk about war i always
think that the people that we have to
make sure that a war is really necessary
uh in order to protect are the people
that you're going to send over there to
fight that
the greatest victims in our society of
war are often the warriors
so i in my mind um you know when we see
these people coming home from places
like iraq a place where
i would have made the argument and did
at the time that we didn't belong
to me those people are victims and i
know they don't like to think about
themselves that way because it runs
totally counter to the
to the ethos but if you're sending
people to protect this country's shores
those are heroes if you're sending
people to go
do something that they otherwise
probably don't need to do but they're
there for political reasons or anything
else you want to put in that's not
defense related well then you've made
victims of our heroes and so i
i feel like we do a lot of talk
about our troops and our soldiers and
stuff but we don't treat them
as valuable as we as as the rhetoric
makes them sound otherwise we would be
more um we would be much more careful
about where we put them
if you're going to send my son and i
don't have a son i have daughters but if
you're going to send my son
into harm's way i'm going to demand
that you really need to be sending him
into harm's way and i'm going to be
angry at you
if you put him into harm's way if he
doesn't if it doesn't warrant it
and so i have much more suspicion about
the system that sends these people into
these situations where they're required
to be heroic than i do the people on the
ground that i look at as
um either uh the people that are
defending us
you know in situations like this you
know the second world war for example or
or the people that um
turn out to be the individual victims of
a system
where they're just a cog and a machine
and the machine doesn't really care
as much about them as as the rhetoric
and the propaganda
would insinuate yeah and uh as my own
family history
it would be nice if we could talk about
there's a gray area
in in the places that you're talking
about there's a gray area in everything
and everything
but when that gray area is part of your
own blood
as it is for me it's
it's worth shining a light on somehow
sure give me example what you mean so
you did a program of four episodes of
ghosts of the us front yeah so i was
born
in the soviet union i was raised in
moscow my dad was born and raised in
kiev
my grandmother who just recently passed
away was um
uh raised in ukraine
she it's a small city
on the border between russia and ukraine
i have a grandfather born in kiev
in kiev the interesting thing about the
timing of everything
as you might be able to connect as she
survived
she's the most badass woman of uh i've
ever encountered my life and
most of the warrior spirit i carry is
probably from her
she survived polymor the ukrainian
starvation of the 30s
she was a beautiful teenage girl during
the nazi occupation
of so she survived all of that
and of course family that that everybody
you know
and so many people died the whole
process so
and one of the things you talk about in
your program is that the gray area is
even with the warriors
it happened to them just like as you're
saying now it uh
they didn't have a choice so my my
grandfather on the on the other side
he was uh a machine gunner
uh that was in ukraine that that
in the red army in the red army yeah and
they
through uh like the
the statement was that there's i don't
know if it's obvious or not but the rule
was there's no surrender
so you you better die so you i mean
you're basically the goal was when he
was fighting
and he was lucky enough one of the only
to survive
by being wounded early on is there was a
march
of uh nazis towards i guess moscow
and the whole goal in ukraine was to
slow
everyth to slow them into the into the
winter
i mean i view him as such a hero and
he believed that he's indestructible
which is survivor bias and
that you know bullets can't hurt him and
that's what everybody believed
and of course basically everyone that
uh he quickly rose to the ranks let's
just put it this way
because everybody died it's it's it's
it was just bodies dragging these heavy
machine guns
like always you know i was slowly
retreating
shooting and retreating shooting and
retreating and
i don't know he was a hero to me
like i always i grew up thinking that he
was the one that sort of defeated the
nazis right
and but the reality that there could be
another perspective which is all of this
happened to him
uh by the incompetence of stalin the
incompetent
incompetence and uh
men of uh the soviet union being used
like pawns
in a in a shittily played game of chess
right so like the one
narrative is of him as a victim as as
you're kind of describing
and it then somehow that's more
paralyzing
and that's more i don't know
it feels better to think of him as
a hero and as russia soviet union
saving the world i mean that narrative
also is in the united states that
that uh the united states was key in
saving the world from the nazis
it feels like that narrative is powerful
for people
i'm not sure and i carry it still with
me
but when i think about the right way to
think about that war
i'm not sure if that's the correct
narrative
let me suggest something there's a line
that uh
that a marine named eugene sledge uh
had said once and i i keep it on my
phone because it's it's
it makes a real distinction and he said
the front line is really where the war
is and anybody
even a hundred yards behind the front
line doesn't know what it's really like
now the difference is is there are lots
of people miles
behind the front line that are in danger
right you can be in a medical unit in
the rear
and artillery could strike you planes
could start i mean you could be in
danger
but at the front line there are two
different things one is
um that that and at least and i'm doing
a lot of reading on this right now and
reading a lot of veterans accounts
james jones who wrote uh uh books like
from here to eternity fictional accounts
of the second world war but he based
them on his own
service he was at uh guadalcanal for
example in 1942.
and jones had said that the evolution of
a soldier
in front line action requires an
almost surrendering to the idea that
you're going to live that you
you you become accustomed to the idea
that you're going to die
and he said you're a different person
simply for considering
that thought seriously because most of
us don't but what that allows you to do
is to do that job at the front line
right
if you're too concerned about your own
life
um you become less of a good guy at your
job
right the other thing that the people in
the one in the 100 yards of the front
line do that the people
in the rear medical unit really don't is
you kill
and you kill a lot right you don't just
oh there's a sniper back here so i shot
him
it's we go from one position to another
and we kill lots of people
those things will change you and what
that tends to do
not universally because i've read
accounts from uh red army soldiers and
they're very
patriotic right but a lot of that
patriotism
comes through years later as part of the
nostalgia and the remembering
when you're down at that front 100 yards
it is
often boiled down to a very small world
so your grandfather
was it your grandfather grandfather at
the machine gun
he's concerned about his position and
his comrades and the people who he owes
a responsibility to
and those it's a very small world at
that point and to me that's where the
heroism is right
he's not fighting for some giant world
civilizational thing
he's fighting to save the people next to
him and his own life at the same time
because they're saving him too
and and that there is a huge amount of
heroism to that and that gets to our
question about force earlier
why would you use force well how about
to protect these people on either side
of me right their lives
um now is there hatred
yeah i hated the germans for what they
were doing as a matter of fact i uh
i got a note from a poll not that long
ago
and i have this tendency to refer to the
nazis right the regime that was
and he said why do you keep calling them
nazis he says say say what they were
they were germans
and this guy wanted me to not absolve
germany by saying oh it was this awful
group of people that took over your
country he said the germans did this
and there's that bitterness where he
says let's not forget you know what they
did to us and why
and what we had to do back right um so
for me
when we talk about these combat
situations the reason i call these
people heroic is because of
they're fighting to defend things we
could all understand i mean if you come
after my brother
and i take a machine gun and shoot you
and you're going to overrun me i mean
you're gonna though that becomes a
situation where we talked about counter
force earlier
um much easier to call yourself a hero
when you're saving people
or you're saving this town right behind
you and you know if they get through
your machine gun
they're gonna burn these villages
they're going to throw these people out
in the middle of winter these families
that to me is a very different sort of
heroism than this amorphous idea
of patriotism you know patriotism is a
thing that we often get um
used with right people people manipulate
us
through love of country and all this
because they understand that this is
something we feel very strongly but they
use it against us sometimes
in order to whip up a war fever or to
get people i mean
there's a great line and i wish i could
remember it in its entirety that herman
goering
had said about how easy it was to get
the people into a war
he says you know you just appeal to
their patriotism i mean there's buttons
that you can push and they take
advantage of things like love of country
and the way we um the way we have a
loyalty and admiration to the warriors
who put their lives on the line
these are manipulatable things in the
human species
that reliably can be counted on to
move us in directions that in a more um
sober reflective state of mind we would
consider differently it gets the i mean
you get this war fever up and people
people wave flags and they start
denouncing the enemy and they start
signing
you know we've seen it over and over and
over again in ancient times this
happened
but the love of country is also
beautiful so
i haven't seen it in america as much so
people in america love
their country like this patriotism is
strong in america
but it's not as strong as i remember
even with my
sort of being younger the love of the
soviet union
now was it the soviet union this
requires a distinction or was it
mother russia what it really was was the
communist party
okay so it was this it was the system in
place okay the system in place like
loving i haven't quite deeply
psychologized exactly what you love
i think you love the that like populist
message of the worker
of the common man that's common so let
me let me draw
the comparison then um and i often say
this that that
the united states like the soviet union
is an ideological based society right so
you take a country like france
it doesn't matter which french
government you're in now the french have
been the french for a long time
right uh it's it's not based on an
ideology
right whereas what unites the united
states is an ideology
freedom liberty the constitution this is
what draws you know it's the e pluribus
unum kind of
the idea right this that out of many one
well what what
binds all these unique different people
these shared beliefs
this ideology the soviet union was the
same way because as you know the soviet
union russia was merely one part of the
soviet union
and if you believe the rhetoric until
stalin's time
everybody was going to be united under
this ideological banner someday right it
was a global revolution
um so ideological societies are
different and to be
a fan of the ideological framework and
goal i mean
i'm a liberty person right i would like
to see everybody in the world
have my system of government which is
part of a of a bias
right because they might not want that
but i think it's better for everyone
because i think it's better for me
at the same time when the ideology if
you consider
and you know this stems from ideas of
the enlightenment
and there's a bias there so my bias are
toward the but you feel and this is why
you say we're going to bring freedom to
iraq we're going to bring freedom to
here we're going to bring freedom
because we think we're spreading to you
something that is just
undeniably positive we're going to free
you
and give you this um
it's hard for me to to wipe my own bias
away from there right because if i were
in iraq for example i would want freedom
right
but if you then leave and let the iraqis
vote for whomever they want
are they going to vote for somebody that
will i mean you know
you look at russia now and i hear from
russians quite a bit because so much of
my um
my views on russia and the soviet union
were formed in my formative years
and and you know we were not hearing
from many people in the soviet union
back then but now you do you hear from
russians today who will say
your views on stalin are archaic and
cold you know so
so you try to reorient your beliefs a
little bit but it goes to this idea of
if you gave the people in russia a
free and fair vote will they vote for
somebody who promises them a free and
open
society based on enlightenment
democratic principles or will they vote
for somebody we in the u.s would go
what are they doing they're voting for
some strong man who's just good you know
so
um i think it's very hard to throw away
our own
uh biases and and preconceptions and and
you know it's an all
eye of the beholder kind of thing but
when you're talking about ideological
societies
it is very diff difficult to throw off
all the years of indoctrination into the
superiority of your system
i mean listen in the soviet union
marxism one way or another was part of
every classroom's you know you could be
studying geometry and they'll throw
marxism in there somehow
because that's what united the society
and that's what gave it a higher purpose
and that's what made it in the minds of
the people who were its defenders
a superior morally superior system and
we do the same thing here in fact
most people do but see you're still
french no matter what
what the ideology or the government
might be so so in that sense
it's funny that there would be a cold
war with these two systems because
they're both ideologically based systems
involving peoples of many different
backgrounds
who are united under the umbrella of the
ideology
first of all that's brilliantly put
i'm in a funny position that um in my
formative years i came here when i was
13
is when i you know teenage is your first
love or whatever
as i fall in love i fell in love with
the american set of ideas
of freedom and individuals
but i also remember it's like you
remember like maybe an ex-girlfriend or
something like that
i also remember loving
as a very different human the
the soviet idea like we had the national
anthem
which is still the i think the most
badass national anthem which is the
soviet union
like saying we're the indestructible
nation i mean just the words are so
like americans words are like oh we're
nice like we're freedom
but like a russian soviet union national
anthem was like we're bad [ __ ]
nobody will destroy us
uh i just remember feeling pride in a
nation as a kid like dumb not knowing
anything because
we all had to recite the stuff it was um
there's a uniformity to everything
there's pride underlying everything
i didn't think about all the destructive
nature of
the bureaucracy the incompetence the of
you know all the things that come with
the implementation
of communism especially around the 80s
and 90s but i i remember what it's like
to love
that set of ideas so i'm in a funny
place of like
remember like switching the love because
i'm you know i kind of joke around about
being russian but you know my my
long-term monogamous relationship is not
with the idea
the american ideal like i'm stuck with
it in my mind
but i remember what it was like to love
it and i
and i i think about that too when people
criticize china or they criticize
the current state of affairs with how
stalin is remembered
and how putin is
to know that the you can't always wear
the american ideal of individualism
radical individualism and freedom in
analyzing
the ways of the world elsewhere like in
china
in russia that it does
if you don't take yourself too seriously
as americans all do as i do
it's it's kind of a beautiful love to
have for your government
to believe in the nation to let go
of yourself and your rights and your
freedoms
to believe in something bigger than
yourself that's
actually uh that's a kind of freedom
that's you're actually liberating
yourself if you think like life is
suffering
you're you're giving into the flow of
the water the flow the way of the world
by giving away more power from yourself
and giving it to what you would conceive
as
as the power of the people together
together we'll do great things and
really believing
in the ideals of um what
in that in this case i don't even know
what you would call russia but whatever
the heck that is
authoritarian powerful state
powerful leader believing that can be uh
as beautiful as believing the american
ideal not just that
let me add to what you're saying i'm
very
i spend a lot of time trying to get out
of my own
biases uh it is it is a fruitless
endeavor
long term but you try to be better than
you normally are one of the critiques
that china and i always you know as an
american i tend to think about this as
their government right this is a
rationale that their government puts
forward but what you just said
you know is actually if you can make
that viewpoint beautiful is kind of a
beautiful way of approaching it the
chinese would say
that what we call human rights in the
united states and what we consider to be
everybody's birthright around the world
is instead
western rights that's the words they use
western rights
it's a it's a fundamentally western
oriented
and i'll go back to the enlightenment
enlightenment based ideas
um on what constitutes the rights of man
and they would suggest that that's not
internationally and always applicable
right that you can make a case and again
i don't believe this
this runs against my own personal views
but that you could make a case
that the collective well-being of a very
large group of people
outweighs the individual needs of any
single person especially if
those things are in conflict with each
other right if you cannot provide
for the greater good because everyone's
so individualistic
well then really what is the better
thing to do right to suppress
individualism so everybody's better off
um i think trying to recognize how
someone else might
see that is important if we want to you
know you had talked about eliminating
war we talk about eliminating conflict
uh the first need to do that is to try
to understand
how someone else might view something
differently than yourself
um i'm famously one of those people who
buys in
to the ideas of of traditional
americanism right
and look what a lot of people who who
live today i mean they would seem to
think that things like
um patriotism requires a
belief in the strong military and all
these things we have today but that is a
corruption of traditional americanism
which viewed all those things
with suspicion in the first hundred
years of the republic because they saw
it
as an enemy to the very things that
americans celebrated
right how could you have freedom and
liberty
and individualistic um expression if you
had an overriding military that was
always fighting wars and
and the founders of this country looked
to other examples like europe for
example
and saw that standing militaries for
example standing armies
were the enemy of liberty well we have a
standing army now
um and and one that is totally
interwoven in our entire society if you
could
if you could go back in time and talk to
john quincy adams right early president
of the united states and show him what
we have now
he would think it was awful and horrible
and
somewhere along the line the americans
had lost their way and forgotten what
they were all about
but we have so successfully interwoven
this modern uh military industrial
complex with the the traditional
uh benefits of the american system and
ideology
so that they've become intertwined in
our thinking whereas 150 years ago
they were actually considered to be at
opposite polarities and a threat to one
another
um so when you talk about the love of
the nation
i tend to be suspicious of those things
i tend to be suspicious of government i
tend to tend to
try very hard to not be manipulated and
i feel like
a large part of what they do is
manipulation and propaganda
and so um i think a healthy skepticism
of the nation state is actually 100
americanism in the traditional sense of
the word but i also have to recognize as
you so eloquently stated
americanism is not necessarily universal
at all
and so i think we have to try to be more
understanding
see our the the traditional american
viewpoint
is that if a place like china does not
allow their people individual human
rights
then they're being denied something
they're being denied
and 100 years ago they would have said
they're god given rights
man is born free and if he's not free
it's because of something done to him
right the government has taken away his
god-given rights
i'm getting excited just listening to
that well but i mean but i mean i think
i think the idea that this is universal
is in and of itself a bias now do i want
freedom for everybody else
i sure do but the people in the soviet
union who really bought into that
wanted the workers of the world to unite
and not be exploited by
you know the the greedy blood-sucking
people who worked them to death and
pocketed all of the fruits of their
labor if you frame it that way that
sounds like justice as well
you know so it is an eye of the beholder
sort of thing
i'd love to talk to you about
vladimir putin sort of
while we're on this feeling and wave of
empathy
and trying to understand others that are
not like us
one of the reasons i started this
podcast
is because i believe that there's a few
people i could talk to
some of it is ego some of it
stupidity is there some people i could
talk to
that not many others can talk to
the one person i was always thinking
about was vladimir putin
do you still speak the language i speak
the language very well that makes it
even easier i mean you might be you
might be appointed for that job
that's the context in which i'm asking
you this question what
are your thoughts about vladimir putin
from historical context have you
studied him have you thought about him
yes uh
studied as a is a loaded word um
here's here's and again i i find it hard
sometimes to not
filter things through an american lens
so as an american
i would say that the russians should be
allowed to have any leader that they
want to have
but what an american would say is but
there should be elections
right so if the russians choose vladimir
putin
and they keep choosing him that's their
business
where where as an american i would have
a problem is when that leader
stops letting the russians make that
decision and we would say well
now you're no longer ruling by the
consent of the governed
you've become the equivalent of a person
who may be oppressing your people you
might as well be a dictator
right now there's a difference between a
freely elected and re-elected and
re-elected and re-elected dictator
right if that's what they want and and
look i i it would be silly to broad
brush the russians like it would be
silly to broad-brush
anyone right millions and millions of
people with different opinions amongst
them all
but they seem to like a strong person at
the helm and listen there's a giant
chunk of americans who do too
um in their own country but an american
would say
as long as the freedom of choice is is
given to the russians to decide this
and not taken away from them right it's
one thing to say he was freely elected
but a long time ago and we've done away
with elections since then
is is a different story too so my
attitude on on vladimir putin is if
that's who the russian people want
and you give them the choice right if
he's only there because they keep
electing him
that's a very different story when he
stops
offering them the option of choosing him
or not choosing him
that's when it begins to look nefarious
to someone born and raised
with the mindset and the ideology that
is an integral part of
of yours truly and that i can't you know
you can see gray areas and nuance all
you like but it's hard to escape as you
wish and you you alluded to this too
it's hard to escape what was
indoctrinated into your bones in your
formative years
uh it's like exit you know your bones
are growing right
and you can't go back so to me this is
so much a part of who i am
that i have a hard time jettisoning that
and saying oh no vladimir putin not
being elected anymore it's just fine
i'm too much of a product of my
upbringing to go there does that make
sense yeah
absolutely but of course there's like
what we're saying there's gray areas
which is
i believe i have to think through this
but i
think there is a point at which adolf
hitler became
the popular choice in nazi germany in
the 30s
there's a in in the same way
from an american perspective you can
start to criticize
some in a shallow way some in a deep way
the way that putin has maintained power
is by controlling the press so limiting
one other freedom that we americans
value which is
the the freedom of the press or freedom
of speech that
he it is very possible now things are
changing now but for most of his
presidency
he was the popular choice and sometimes
by far
and you know i have i actually don't
have real family in russia who don't
love putin
i the only people who write to me about
putin
and not liking him are like sort of
activists who are young right
but like to me they're strangers i don't
know anything about them
the people i do know have a big family
in russia
they love putin they
do they miss elections
would they want the choice to prove it
at the ballot box
and and or or are they so in love with
him
that they're they wouldn't want to take
a chance that someone might vote him out
no they don't think of it this way and
they are aware
of the incredible bureaucracy and
corruption
that is lurking in the shadows which is
true in russia
right everywhere everywhere but like
there's something about the russian
it's a remnants it's corruption is so
deeply part of the russians so the
soviet system
that even the overthrow of the soviet
the the
the breaking apart of the soviet union
and
uh putin coming and reforming a lot of
the system
it's still deeply in there and and
they're aware of that
that's part of the like the love for
putin is partially grounded
in the fear of what happens
when the corrupt take over the greedy
take over
and they they see putin as the
stabilizer as like
a hard like force that says
counterforce counterforce like get your
[ __ ] together
like basically from the western
perspective putin is
is terrible but from
from the russian perspective putin is is
the only thing holding this thing
together before it goes
if it collapses now the from the like
gary kasparov has been loud on this
you know a lot of people from the
western perspective say
well if it has to collapse let it
collapse you know
that's easier said than done when you
don't have to live through that exactly
and so anyone worrying about their
family about and they also
remember the
the inflation and the economic
instability and the suffering and the
starvation that happened in the 90s with
the collapse of the soviet union
and they saw the kind of reform and the
economic vibrancy that happened when
putin took power
that they think like this guy's holding
it together
and they see elections
as potentially being
mechanisms by which the corrupt people
can manipulate the system
unfairly as opposed to letting the
people speak with their voice
they somehow figure out a way to uh
manipulate the elections to elect
somebody uh
like one of them western revolutionaries
and so i think one of the beliefs
that's important to the american system
is the belief
in the electoral system that
the voice of the people can be heard in
the various systems of
government whether it's judicial whether
it's uh
uh i mean basically the assumption is
that the system works well enough for
you to
be able to uh elect the popular choice
okay so there's a couple of things that
come to mind on that
the first one has to do with the idea of
oligarchs
um there's a belief in political science
uh
you know it's not the overall belief but
but that every society is sort of an
oligarchy really if you break it down
right so what you're talking about are
some of the people who would form
an oligarchic class in in in russia
and that putin is the guy who can
harness
uh the power of the state to keep those
people in check
the problem of course in a system like
that a strong man system
right where you have somebody who can
who can hold the reins and steer the
ship when the ship is
violently in a storm is the succession
so if you're not creating a system
that can operate without you then that
terrible instability and that terrible
future that you
that you justified the strong man for is
just awaiting
your future right i mean unless unless
he's actively building
the system that will outlive him and
allow successors
to do what he's doing then then what
you've done here is create a temporary i
would think a temporary stability here
because
it's the same problem you have in a
monarchy right um where
where you have this one king and he's
particularly good or you think he's
particularly good
but he's going to turn that job over to
somebody else down the road
and the system doesn't guarantee because
no one's really worked on and again you
would tell me if if putin is putting
into place
i know he's talked about it over the
years putting into place a system that
can outlive him
and that will create the stability that
the people in russia
like him for when he's gone because if
the oligarchs just take over
afterwards then one might argue well we
had 20 good years you know of stability
but i mean i would say that if we're
talking about a ship of state here
the guy steering the ship maybe if you
want to look at it from the russian
point of view has done a great job maybe
just saying but the rocks are still out
there and he's not going to be at
the helm forever so one would think that
his job is to make sure that
there's going to be someone who can
continue to steer the ship for the
people of russia after he's gone
now let me ask because i'm curious
and and ignorant so uh is he doing that
do you think
is he setting it up so that when there
is no putin
the state is safe from the beginning
that was the
idea whether one of the fascinating
things now i read every biography
english
written biography on putin so i haven't
i need to think more deeply but one of
the fascinating things is how did power
change vladimir putin he was a different
man when he took power than he is today
i actually in many ways admired the man
that took power
i think is he's very different than
stalin and then hitler
at the moment they took power i think
hitler
and stalin were both in our previous
discussion
already on the trajectory of evil i
think putin
was a humble loyal
honest man when he took power the man he
is today
is worth thinking about and studying i'm
not sure
that that that's an old line though
about absolute power corrupting
absolutely
but it's you know it's kind of a line
uh you know it's it's a beautiful quote
but you have to really think about it
you know like what does that actually
mean
like one of the things i i still have to
do you know i've been focusing on
securing the conversation right so i
i've been i haven't gone through a dark
place yet because i feel like i can't do
the dark thing
for too long so i really have to put
myself in the mind
of putin leading up to the conversation
but for now my senses his
he took power when yeltsin
gave him one of the big sort of acts of
the new russia
was for the first time in its history
a leader could have continued being in
power
and chose to give away power that was
the george washington
right in the united states would look at
that as absolute positive yeah a sign
a sign of good things yes and so that
was a huge act
and uh putin said that that
that was the defining thing that will
define russia for the 21st century that
act
and he will carry that flag forward
that's why
in rhetoric he after two terms
he gave away power to medvedev yeah but
it was a puppet right
yeah yes but it was but like
still the story was being told i think
he believed it
early on i think he
i believe he still believes it but i
think he's deeply suspicious
of the corruption that looks in the
shadows and i
i do believe that like as somebody who
thinks clickbait journalism is broken
journalists annoy the hell out of me hey
journalism's working perfectly
journalism's broken journalists made
things working great
so i understand from putin's perspective
that journalism journalists can be seen
as the enemy of the state because
people think journalists write these
deep
beautiful philosophical pieces about
criticizing the structure of government
and the
proper policy what you know the steps
that we need to take
to make a greater nation no they they're
unfairly take stuff out of context
they uh they're critical in ways that's
like
shallow and not interesting they they
call you a racist
or sexist or they make up stuff all the
time
so i can put myself in the mindset of a
person that thinks that
it is okay to remove that kind of
shallow
uh fake news voice from the system
the problem is of course that is a
slippery slope to
then you remove all the annoying people
from the system
and then you change what annoying means
which annoying starts becoming a thing
that like
anyone who opposes the the system i mean
i get
i get the um the slippery
it's obvious it becomes a slippery slope
but i can also put myself
in the mindset of the people that see
it's okay to remove the liars from the
system
as long as it's good for russia and okay
so here in lies and this again the
traditional american perspective because
we've had yellow so-called yellow
journalism since the founding of the
republic that's nothing new
um but but the problem then comes into
play
when you remove journalists even you
know
it's a broad brush thing because but you
remove both the the crappy ones who are
lying
and the ones who are telling the truth
too you're left with simply
the the approved government journalists
right the ones who are toeing
the government's line in which case the
truth
as you see it is a different kind of
fake news right it's the fake news from
the government
instead of the click bait news and oh
yeah maybe
truth mixed into all that too in some of
the outlets
the problem i always have with our
system here in the united states right
now is
trying to tease the truth out from all
the falsehoods
and look i've got 30 years in journalism
my job used to be to go through
before the internet all the newspapers
and and find the i used to know all the
journalists by name and i could pick out
you know who they were
and and and i have a hard time picking
out the truth from the falsehood so i
think constantly
how are people who don't have all this
background who have lives or who are
trained in other specialties
how do they do it but if the government
is the only approved
outlet for truth a traditional american
and a lot of other traditional societies
based on these ideas of the
enlightenment that i talked about
earlier
would see that as a disaster waiting to
happen or a tyranny in progress does
that make sense
it totally makes sense and i would agree
with you i still agree with you
but it is clear that something about the
freedom
of the press and freedom of speech
in today like literally the last few
years with the internet
is changing and the argument you know
you could say that the american system
of freedom of speech
is is broken because the
here's here's the belief i grew up on
and i still hold
but i'm starting to be sort of trying to
see multiple
views on it my belief was that freedom
of speech
results in a stable trajectory towards
truth
always so like truth will emerge that
was my sort of faith and belief that
that yeah there's going to be lies all
over the place but there will be like a
stable
thing that is true that's carried
forward
to the public now it feels like
it's possible to go towards a world
where nothing
is true or truth is is something that
groups of people convince themselves of
and there's multiple groups of people
and the idea of some universal truth as
i suppose is the better
thing is uh is something that we can no
longer
exist under like some people believe
that the green bay packers is the best
uh football team and some people can
think the patriots
and they deeply believe it to where they
call the other groups liars
now that's fun for sports that's fun for
favorite flavors of ice cream
but they might believe that about
science about
uh various aspects of uh
politics various aspects of
sort of uh different policies within
the function of our government and like
that's not just like
some weird thing we complain about but
that'll be the nature of things like
truth is something we could no longer
have well let's and let me
de-romanticize the american
history of this too because the american
press
was often just as biased just as i mean
i always looked to the 1970s as the high
water mark of the american
journalistic in the post-watergate era
where it was actively going after
um the abuses of the government and all
these things but there was a famous
speech
very quiet though very quiet given by
catherine graham who was a
washington post editor i believe and uh
i actually somebody sent it to me we had
to get it off of a journalism
like a jstor kind of thing and she
at a at a luncheon um assured that the
to the government people at the luncheon
don't worry this is not going to be
something that we make a trend
we're not because the position
of the government is still something
that was
carried you know the the newspapers were
the water and the newspapers were the
big thing up until certainly
the late 60s early 70s the newspapers
were still the water carrier of the
government right and they were the water
carriers of the owners of the newspaper
so let's not pretend there was some
angelic wonderful time and i'm saying to
me because i was the one who brought it
up
let's not pretend there was any super
age of truthful journalism and all that
and i mean you go to the
revolutionary period in american history
and it looks every bit as bad as today
right um that's a hopeful message
actually so things may not be as bad as
they look well let's look at it more
like a stock market and that you have
fluctuations
in the truthfulness or or believability
of the press
and there are periods where it was
higher than other periods
the funny thing about the so-called
click-bait era and i do think it's
terrible
but i mean it resembles earlier eras to
me
so i always compare it to when i was a
kid growing up when i thought journalism
was as good as it's ever gotten it was
never perfect
um but it's also something that you see
very rarely
in in other governments around the world
and there's a reason that journalists
are often
killed uh regularly in a lot of
countries
and it's because they report on things
that the authorities do not want
reported on and i've always thought that
that was what journalism should do
but it's got to be truthful otherwise
it's just a different kind of propaganda
right
can we talk about genghis khan genghis
khan
sure by the way is it genghis khan or
genghis khan
it's not genghis khan it's either
genghis khan or chingas khan
so let's go with the genghis khan the
only thing i'll be able to say with any
certain
last certain thing i'll say about it uh
it's like i don't know
gif versus jif i don't know
how i don't know how it ever got started
the wrong way
yeah so first of all your episodes on uh
genghis khan for many people are
the favorite it's fascinating to think
about events that had so much
like in their ripples had so much impact
on
so much of human civilization in your
view
was he an evil man
this goes to our discussion of evil
another way to put it is i've read
he's much loved in much part in many
parts of the world like mongolia
and i've also read arguments that say
that
he was quite a progressive for the time
so where do you put him is he a
progressive or is he an evil destroyer
of
humans as i often say i'm not a
historian which is why
what i try to bring to the hardcore
history podcasts
are these sub themes so each show has
and they're not i try to kind of soft
pedal them so they're not always like
really right in front of your face
um in that episode the soft pedaling sub
theme had to do with what we uh referred
to as a historical arsonist
and it's because some historians have
taken the position
that sometimes and and most of this is
earlier so historians don't do this very
much anymore but these were the
wonderful questions i grew up with
that blend it's almost the intersection
between history and philosophy
and the idea was that sometimes
the world has become so overwhelmed with
bureaucracy
or corruption or just stagnation
that somebody has to come in or some
group of people or some force has to
come in and do the equivalent of a
forest fire
to clear out all the dead wood so that
the forest itself can be rejuvenated
and and society can then move forward
and there's a lot of these periods where
the historians
of the past will portray these figures
who come in and do horrific
things as creating an almost service
for for mankind right uh creating the
foundations
for a new world that will be better than
the old one and it's a recurring theme
and so this was the sub theme
of the of the cons podcast because
otherwise you don't need me to tell you
the story of the mongols but i'm going
to bring up the
historical arsonist element um and but
this gets to how the khan has been
portrayed right
if you want to say oh yes he cleared out
the dead wood and made for a for
well then it's a positive thing if you
say my family was in the forest fire
that he set it you're not going to see
it that way
um much of what genghis khan is credited
with on the upside right
so things like religious toleration and
you'll say well he was uh
religiously the mongols were religious
uh religiously tolerant
and so this makes them almost like a
liberal reformer kind of thing
but this needs to be seen within the
context of of their empire which was
uh very much like the roman viewpoint
which is the romans didn't care
a lot of time what your local people
worshipped they wanted stability
and if that kept stability and kept you
paying taxes and didn't require the
legionaries to come in and and
then they didn't care right and and the
cons were the same way like they don't
care what you're practicing as long as
it doesn't disrupt their empire and
cause them
trouble but what i always like to point
out is yes but the khan could still come
in with his representatives to your town
decide your daughter was a beautiful
woman that they wanted in the khan's
concubine
and they would take them so how liberal
an empire is this
right so so many of the things that they
get credit for as though there's some
kind of nice guys
may in another way of looking at it just
be a simple mechanism of control
right a way to keep the empire stable
they're not doing it out of the goodness
of their heart they have decided that
this is the best
and i love because the mongols were
what we would call a pagan people now i
love the fact that they
and i think we call it i forgot the term
we used it had to do with like they were
hedging their bets religiously right
they didn't know which god was the right
one so as long as you're all praying for
the health of the khan we're maximizing
the chances that whoever the gods are
they get the message right
um so i think it's been portrayed as
something
like a liberal empire and it the idea of
mongol universality universality is it's
more about
conquering the world and it's like
saying you know we're going to bring
stability to the world by conquering it
well what if that's hitler
right he could make the same case or
hitler wasn't really the world conqueror
like that because he wouldn't have been
he wouldn't have been trying to make it
equal for all peoples but my point being
that it kind of takes the positive moral
slant
out of it if their motivation wasn't a
positive moral slant
to the motivation and and the mongols
didn't
see it that way and and i think the way
that it's portrayed
is like and i always like to use this
this this analogy but it's like
um shooting an arrow and painting a
bullseye around it afterwards
right how how do we how do we justify
and make them look good in a way
that they themselves probably and unless
we don't have the mongol
point of view per se i mean there's
something called the secret history of
the mongols and there's
things written down by mongolian
overlords through people like persian
and chinese scribes later
we don't have their point of view but it
sure doesn't look
like this was an attempt to create some
wonderful place where everybody was
living a better life than they were
before
i i think that's that's later people uh
putting a nice rosy spin on it so but
there's an aspect to it
maybe you can correct me because i'm
projecting sort of my idea of what it
would take to
to uh to conquer so much land
is uh the ideology
is emergent so if i were to guess
the mongols started out as
exceptionally as warriors who valued
excellence in skill of killing not even
killing but like the
the actual practice of war and it can
start out small
you can grow and grow and grow and then
in order to maintain the stability
of the things over which of the
conquered lands
you developed a set of ideas with which
you can
like you said establish control but it
was emergent
and it seems like the core first
principle idea of the mongols
is just to be excellent warriors that
felt
that felt to me like the starting point
it wasn't some ideology
like with hitler and stalin with hitler
the there was an ideology that didn't
have anything to do with
with war underneath it it was more about
conquering it feels like
the mongols started out more organically
i would say
it's emerg like this phenomenon started
emergently and they were just
like similar to the native americans
with the comanches like the different
warrior tribes that joe rogan's
currently obsessed with
at the that what led me to look into it
more
they they seem to just start out just
valuing the skill
of fighting whatever the tools of war
they had which were pretty primitive
but just to be the best warriors they
could possibly be make a science out of
it
is that is that crazy to think that
there was no ideology behind it in the
beginning
i'm gonna back up a second i'm reminded
of the lines said about the romans that
they create a wasteland
and call it peace that is wow that but
but but there's a lot of conquerors like
that
right um where where uh you you will sit
there and listen historians forever have
it's it's the trait it's the famous
trade-offs of empire
and they'll say well look at the trade
that they facilitated and look at you
know the religion
all those kinds of things but they come
at the cost
of all those peoples that they conquered
forcibly and and
and by force integrated into their
empire
the one thing we need to remember about
the mongols that makes them different
than say the romans
and this is complex stuff and way above
my pay grade but i'm fascinated with it
and it's more like the comanches that
you just brought up is that the mongols
are not a settled
society okay they are they are they come
from a nomadic tradition now several
generations later
when you have a kubila khan as as the
as the emperor of china it's it's
beginning to be a different thing right
and the mongols when their empire broke
up the ones that were
uh in settle the so-called settled
societies right iran places like that
they will become more like over time the
rulers of those places were
traditionally
and the mongols and say like the the
cognate of the golden horde which is
still in
in their traditional nomadic territories
will remain traditionally more mongol
but when you start talking about who the
mongols were
i try to to make a distinction they're
not
some really super special people
they're just the latest confederacy
in an area that saw nomadic
confederacies
going back to the beginning of recorded
history
the scythians the sarmatians the avars
the huns the magyars i mean these are
all the nomadic you know the nomads of
the eurasian steppe were
huge huge players in the history of the
world until gunpowder
nullified their their traditional weapon
system which i've been fascinated with
because
their traditional weapon system is not
one you could copy
because you were talking about being the
greatest warriors you could be
every warrior society i've ever seen
values that
what this what the nomads had of the
eurasian step was this
relationship between human beings and
animals
that changed the equation it was how
they rode
horses and societies like the byzantines
which would form one flank of the step
and then all the way on the other side
you had china and below that you had
persia these societies would all attempt
to create mounted horsemen who used
archery
and they did a good job but they were
never the equals
of the nomads because those people were
literally raised in the saddle
they compared them to centaurs the
comanches great example considered to be
the best
horse riding warriors in north america
the comanches i always loved watching
there's paintings george catlin
the famous uh um uh painter who painted
the comanches
uh illustrated it but the mongols and
the scythians and scythians and the
avars and all these people did it too
where they would shoot from underneath
the horse's
neck hiding behind the horse the whole
way
you look at a picture of somebody doing
that and it's insane
this is what the byzantines couldn't do
and the chinese couldn't do
it was a different level of of
harnessing a human animal relationship
that gave them a military advantage
that could not be copied right it could
be emulated but they were never as good
right
that's why they always hired these
people they hired mercenaries from these
areas because
they were incomparable right so the
combination of people who were shooting
bows and
arrows from the time they were toddlers
who were riding from the time they were
who rode all the time i mean they were
the huns were bow-legged the romans said
because they were never out
they ate slapped everything in the
saddle
that creates something that is difficult
to copy
and it gave them a military advantage uh
you know
i enjoy reading actually about uh when
that military advantage ended so
17th and 18th century when the chinese
on one flank and the russians on the
other are beginning to use firearms and
stuff to break
this military power of these of these
various cons
um the mongols were simply the most
dominating and most successful
of the confederacies but if you break it
down they really
formed the nucleus at the top of the
pyramid of the apex of the food chain
and a lot of the people that were known
as mongols were really
lots of other tribes non-mongolian
tribes that when the mongols conquer you
after they killed a lot of you
they incorporated you into their
confederacy
and often made you go first you know
you're going to fight somebody we're
going to make these people go out in
front and suck up all the arrows
before we go in and finish the job so to
me
and i guess a fan of the mongols would
say that the difference
and what made the mongols different
wasn't the weapon system or the fighting
or the warriors or the armor or anything
it was genghis khan and if you go look
at the other
really dangerous from the outside
world's perspective dangerous
step nomadic confederacies from past
history was always when
some great leader emerged that could
unite the tribes and you see the same
thing in native american history two
degree two
um you had people like attila right
or uh there was one called twomin you go
back in history and these people
make the history books because they
caused an enormous amount of trouble for
their settled neighbors
that normally i mean chinese byzantine
and persian
approaches to the steppe people were
always the same they would pick out
tribes to be friendly with they would
give them money gifts hire them
and they would use them against the
other tribes and generally
byzantine especially in chinese
diplomatic history was all about keeping
these tribes separated don't let them
form confederations of large numbers of
them because then they're unstoppable
attila was a perfect example the huns
were another large
the turks another large confederacy of
these people and they were
devastating when they could unite so the
diplomatic policy was don't let them
that's what made the mongols different
is genghis khan united them and then
unlike most of the tribal confederacies
he was able they were able to hold it
together for a few generations
to linger on the little thread
they started pulling on this man
genghis khan that was a leader yeah
what do you think makes a great leader
maybe if you have other examples
throughout history and great
again let's lose that use that term
loosely
now he's gonna ask for a definition
great uniter
of whether it's evil or good it doesn't
matter
is there somebody who stands out to you
alexander the grace
talking about military or ideologies you
know some people bring up fdr
or or i mean it could be the founding
fathers of this country
or we can go to uh was he mana
uh man of the century up there hitler
of uh the 20th century
and stalin and these people had really
uh amassed the amount of power that
probably has never been seen in the
history of the world
is there somebody who stands out to you
by way of
uh trying to define what makes a great
uniter great leader
in one man or a woman maybe in the
future
it's an interesting question and one
i've thought a lot about because
let's take alexander the great as an
example because alexander fascinated the
world of his time
fascinated ever since people have been
fascinated with the guy
but alexander was a hereditary monarch
right yeah he he was handed the kingdom
which is fascinating right but he did
not need
to rise from nothing to get that job
in fact he reminds me of a lot of other
leaders of frederick the great for
example
in prussia these are people who
inherited
the greatest army of their day
alexander unless he was in imbecile was
going to be
great no matter what because i mean if
you inherit the wehrmacht
you're going to be able to do something
with it right alexander's father
may have been greater philip uh he
philip ii was the guy
who who literally did create a
a strong kingdom from a disjointed
group of people that were continually
beset by their neighbors he's the one
that reformed that army
uh took things that he had learned from
other uh greek leaders like the theban
leader at pemanandes
um and and then laboriously
over his lifetime stabilized the
frontiers built this system
he lost an eye doing it he he he his leg
was made lame
i mean he this was a man who looked like
he built the empire and
led from from the front ranks i mean um
so and then and then
who may have been killed by his son we
don't know who assassinated philip
um but then handed the greatest army the
world had ever seen to his son
who then did great things with it you
see this this pattern
many times so in my mind i'm not sure
alexander really can be that great
when you compare him to people who arose
from nothing so the difference between
what we would call
in the united states the self-made man
or the one who inherits a fortune
there's an old line that you know it's a
slur but uh it's about rich people and
it's
like he was born on he was born on third
base and thought he hit a triple
right um philip was born at home plate
and he had to hit
alexander started on third base and so i
try to draw a distinction
between them genghis khan is tough
because there's two traditions
the tradition that we grew up with here
in the united states and that i grew up
learning was that he was a self-made man
but there is a tradition and it may be
one of those things that's put after the
fact because a lot a long time ago
whether or not you had blue blood in
your veins was an
important distinction and so the
distinction that you'll often hear from
mongolian history
uh is that this was a a nobleman who had
been deprived of his inheritance so he
was a blue blood anyway
i don't know which is true uh there's
certainly i mean when you look at a
genghis khan though you have to go
that is a wicked amount of things to
have achieved
uh he's very impressive as a figure
attila is very impressive as a figure
um hitler's an interesting figure he's
one of those people
cuz you know the more you study about
hitler the more you wonder
where the defining moment was
because um if you look at his life i
mean hitler was a relatively
common soldier in the first world war i
mean he was brave he got uh
he got some decorations in fact the
highest decoration he got in the first
world war was given to him by a jewish
officer and it was uh he often didn't
talk about that decoration even though
it was the more prestigious one because
it would open up a whole can of worms
you didn't want to get into
but hitler's i mean if you said who was
hitler today
one of the top things you're going to
say is he was an anti-semite
well then you have to draw a distinction
between general
regular anti-semi-semitism that was
pretty common in the era
and something that was a rabid level of
anti-semitism but hitler didn't seem to
show a
rabid level of anti-semitism until after
or at the very end of the first world
war
so if this is a defining part of this
person's character
and and much of what we consider to be
his his evil
stems from that what happened to this
guy when he's an
adult right he's already fought in the
war to change him so i mean it's almost
like the old there was always a movie
theme somebody gets
hit by by something on the head and
their whole personality changes right
i mean it almost seems something like
that so i don't think i call that
necessarily a great leader
to me the interesting thing about hitler
is what the hell happened to a
non-descript person who didn't really
impress
anybody with his skills and then in in
the 1920s it's all of a sudden
as you said sort of the man of the hour
right so that to me is kind of fast
i have this feeling that genghis khan
and we don't really know
was an impressive human being from the
get-go and then he was raised in this
environment with pressure on all sides
so
you start with this diamond and then you
polish it and you harden it his whole
life
hitler seems to be a very unimpressive
gemstone
most of his life and then all of a
sudden so i mean
i don't think i can label great leaders
and i'm always fascinated by that idea
that
and i'm trying to remember who the quote
was by that that great men oh lord acton
so great men
are often not good men uh and that in
order to be
great you would have to jettison many of
the moral qualities that we normally
would consider
a jesus or a gandhi or you know these
these qualities that one looks at as
as the good upstanding moral qualities
that we should all aspire to as examples
right the buddha whatever it might be
um those people wouldn't make good
leaders because what you need to be a
good leader often requires the kind of
choices
that a true philosophical diogenes moral
man
wouldn't make yeah um so i don't have an
answer to your question how about that
that's a very long way of saying i don't
know
just linger a little bit it does feel
like from my
study of hitler that the time molded the
man
versus genghis khan where it feels like
he
the man molded his time yes and i feel
that way about a lot of those nomadic uh
confederacy builders
that they really seem to be these
figures that
that stand out as extraordinary for one
in one way or another remembering by the
way that almost all the history of them
were written by the enemies that they so
mistreated that they were probably never
going to get any good press they didn't
write
themselves that's a caveat we should
always yeah basically nomadic or native
american peoples or tribal peoples
anywhere
generally do not get the advantage of
being able to write the history of their
heroes
okay i've uh i've recently almost done
with the rise in the fall of the third
reich it's
one of the historical
descriptions of hitler's rise to power
nazis rise to power there's a few
philosophical things i'd like
to uh ask you to see if you can help
like one of the things i think about is
how does one be a hero in 1930s nazi
germany what does it mean
to be a hero what do heroic actions
look like i think about that because
i think about how i move about
in this world today you know
that we live in really chaotic intense
times
where i don't think you want to draw any
parallels between nazi germany and
modern day
in any of the nations we can think about
but it's not out of the realm of
possibility that authoritarian
governments take hold authoritarian
companies
take hold and i'd like to think that i
could be
in my little small way and inspire
others to take
the heroic action before things get bad
and i kind of try to place myself
in what would 1930s germany look like
is it possible to stop a hitler
is it even the right way to think about
it
and how does one be a hero in it i mean
you often talk about that living through
a moment in history is very different
than looking at that history looking
you know when you look back i also think
about
it would it be possible to understand
what's happening
that the bells of war are are
are ringing uh it seems that most people
didn't seem to understand
on you know late into the 30s that war
is coming
that's fascinating on the united states
side
inside germany like the opposing figures
the german military didn't seem to
understand this
maybe off the other country certainly
france and
england didn't seem to understand this
that kind of tried to put myself
into 90s 30s germany as i'm jewish
which is another little twist on the
whole
like what would i do what should one do
do do you have interesting answers
so earlier we had talked about putin and
we had talked about patriotism and love
of country and those sorts of things
in order to be a hero
in nazi germany by our
views here you would have had to have
been
anti-patriotic to the average germans
viewpoint in the 1930s right you would
have to have opposed your own
government and your own country and
that's a very
it would be a very weird thing to go to
people in germany and say
listen the only way you're going to be
seen as as a good german
and a hero to the country that will be
your
you know enemies is we think you should
oppose your own government it's
it's a strange position to put the
people in a government in
saying you need to be against your
leader you need to oppose your
government's policies you need to oppose
your government
you need to hope and work for its
downfall that doesn't sound patriotic it
wouldn't sound patriotic here in this
country if you if you made a similar
argument
i will go away from the 1930s and go to
the 1940s to answer your questions
there's movements like the white rose
movement in germany
which involved young people really and
from
various backgrounds religious
backgrounds often
who worked openly against the nazi
government at a time when power was
already consolidated the gestapo was in
full
force and they execute people who are
against the government
and these young people would go out and
distribute pamphlets
and many of them got their heads cut off
with guillotines for their trouble
and they knew that that was going to be
the penalty
that is a remarkable amount of bravery
and sacrifice and willingness to die
and almost not even willingness because
they were so open about it it's almost a
certainty
right um that's incredibly moving to me
so when we talk and we had talked
earlier about sort of the
human spirit and all that kind of thing
there are people in the german military
who opposed and worked against hitler
for example
but to me that's almost cowardly
compared to what these young people did
in the white rose movement because
those people in the in the vermont for
example who were secretly trying to
undermine hitler they're
they're not really putting their lives
on the line to the same degree
um and so i i think when i look at
heroes
and listen i remember once saying there
were no conscientious
objectors in in germany as a way to
point out
to people that you didn't have a choice
you know you were going to serve in
there and i got letters from jehovah's
witnesses who said
yes there were and we got sent to the
concentration camps
those are remarkably brave things it's
one thing to have
your own um set of of standards and
values
it's another thing to say oh no i'm
going to display them in a way that with
this regime that's a death sentence and
not just for me
for my family right in these regimes
there was not a lot of distinction made
between father and son and wives
that's a remarkable sacrifice to make
and and far beyond what i think i would
even be capable of and so the admiration
comes from
seeing people who appear to be more
morally
profound than you are yourself um so
when i look at this i look at that
that kind of thing and i just say wow
and the funny thing is if you'd have
gone to most
average germans on the street in 1942
and said what do you think of these
people they're going to think of them as
traders who probably got what they
deserved
so that's the eye of the beholder thing
it's the power of the state
to um to so propagandize values and
morality in a way that favors the state
uh that you can turn people who today we
look at as unbelievably brave and moral
and crusading for righteousness and turn
them into enemies of the people
um so i mean in my mind it would be
people like that
see i i think so
hero is a funny word and we romanticize
the notion
but if i could drag you back to 1930s
germany from 1940s
sure i feel like
the heroic actions that doesn't
accomplish much
is not what i'm referring to so
there's many heroes i look up to
that uh like david goggins for example
the
the guy who runs crazy distances he runs
for no purpose except for the suffering
in itself
and i think his willingness to challenge
the limits of his mind
is uh is heroic i guess i'm looking for
a different term
which is how could hitler have been
stopped
my sense is that he could have been
stopped in the battle of ideas
where or people millions of people were
suffering economically
or suffering because of the betrayal of
world war one
in terms of the love of country and how
they felt they were being treated
and a charismatic leader that inspired
love
and unity that's not destructive could
have emerged
and that's where the battle should have
been fought i would suggest
that we need to take into account the
context of the times that led to
hitler's rise of power and and
and created the conditions where his
message resonated
uh that is not a message that resonates
at all times
right um it is impossible to understand
the the rise of hitler without dealing
with the first world war and the
aftermath of the first world war and the
inflationary terrible depression in
germany and all these things and
the um dissatisfaction with the weimar
republic's government which was often
seen as uh
as uh something put into which it was
put into place by the
the victorious powers uh hitler referred
to the people that signed those
agreements uh
that that signed the armistice as the
november criminals
and he used that as a phrase which
resonated with the population this was a
population that was embittered
and even if they weren't embittered the
times were so terrible and the options
for operating within the system in a
non-radical way
seemed totally discredited right you
could work through the weimar republic
but they tried and it wasn't working
anyway
and then the alternative to the nazis
who were bully boys in the street
were communist agitators that to the
average conservative germans seem no
better
so you have three options if you're an
average german person you can go with
the discredited
government put in power by your enemies
that wasn't working anyway
you could go with the nazis who seemed
like a bunch of super patriots calling
for
uh the restoration of german authority
or you could go with the communists and
the entire thing
seemed like a litany of poor options
right
and in this realm hitler was able to
triangulate if you will
um he came off
as a person who was going to restore
german greatness at a time when this was
a powerful message but if you don't need
german greatness restored it doesn't
resonate
right um so the reason that your love
idea and all this stuff i don't think
would have worked in the time period is
because that was not
a commodity that the average german was
in search of then
well it's interesting to think about
whether
greatness can be restored through
mechanisms through ideas that are not so
from our perspective today so
evil i don't know what the right term is
but the war
continued in a way so remember that that
when germany when hitler
is rising to power the french are in
control
of parts of germany right the ruhr uh
one of the main industrial heartlands of
germany was occupied by the french so
there's never
this point where you're allowed to let
the hate dissipate
right every time maybe things were
calming down
something else would happen to stick the
knife in and twist it a little bit more
from the average german's perspective
right
um the reparations right so if you say
okay well we're going to get back on our
feet the reparations were crushing
these things prevented the idea of love
or brotherhood and all these things from
taking hold
and even if there were germans who felt
that way and there most certainly were
it is hard to overcome the power of
everyone else you know what i always say
when people talk to me about humanity
is i believe on individual levels we're
capable of
everything and anything good bad or
indifferent but
collectively it's different right and in
the time period
that we're talking about here messages
of peace on earth and love your enemies
and and and and all these sorts of
things were absolutely
deluged and overwhelmed and drowned out
by the bitterness the hatred and let's
be honest the sense that you were
continually being abused by your former
enemies
there were a lot of people in the allied
side that realized this and said we're
setting up the next war
this is i mean they understood that you
can only do certain things to collective
human populations
for a certain period of time before it
is natural for them to
want to and there are you can see german
posters from the region nazi
propaganda posters that show them
breaking off the chains of their enemies
and i mean germany awake
right that was the the great um slogan
so
i think love is always a difficult
option
and in the context of those times it it
was even
more disempowered than normal
well this goes to the just to linger in
it for a little longer
the question of the innova inevitability
of history
do you think hitler could have been
stopped do you think
this kind of force that you're saying
that there was a pain
and was building there's a hatred that
was building
do you think there was a way to avert
i mean there's two questions could have
been a lot worse
and could have been better in in the
trajectory of history in the 30s and 40s
the most logical see we had started this
conversation brings a wonderful bow tie
into the discussion
and and and buttons it up nicely we had
talked about force encounter force
earlier uh the most uh obvious and
much discussed way that hitler could
have been stopped has nothing to do with
germans
um when he uh re-militarized the
rhineland
everyone talks about what a couple of
french
divisions would have done had they
simply gone in and contested and this
was something hitler was extremely
i mean it might have been the most
nervous time in his entire career
because he was afraid that they would
have responded with force
and he was in no position to do anything
about it if they did
so this is where you get the people who
say um
you know i mean and churchill's one of
these people too where they talk about
uh that you know he should have been
stopped militarily right at the very
beginning when he was weak
i don't think
listen there were candidates in the in
the in the catholic center party and
others in in the weimar republic
that maybe could have done things and
it's beyond my understanding
of specific german history to talk about
it intelligently
but i do think that had the french
responded militarily to hitler's
initial moves into that area that he
would have been thwarted and
i think he himself believed if i'm
remembering my reading
um that this would have led to his
downfall so the potential see i i
what i don't like about this is that it
almost legitimizes military intervention
at a very early stage to prevent worse
things from happening
but it might be a pretty clear-cut case
but but it should also be pointed out
that there was a lot of sympathy
on the part of the allies for the fact
that you know the germans
probably should have germany back and
this is traditional german land
i mean they were trying in a funny way
it's almost like
the love and the sense of justice on the
allies part
may have actually stayed their hand in a
way
that would have prevented much much much
worse things later but
if the times were such that the message
of a hitler resonated then simply
removing hitler from the equation would
not have removed the context of the
times
and that means one of two things either
you could have had another one
or you could have ended up in a
situation
equally bad in a different direction i
don't know what that means because it's
hard to imagine
anything could be worse than what
actually occurred
but history's funny that way and that
hitler is always
everyone's favorite example of the
difference between the great man theory
of history
and the trends and forces theories of
history right the times made a hitler
possible
and maybe even desirable to some if you
took him out of the equation
those trends and forces are still in
place right so what does that mean
if you take him out and the door is
still open does somebody else walk
through it
yeah it's mathematically speaking the uh
the probability of charismatic leaders
emerge
i i'm so torn on that i i'm uh
uh at this point here's another way to
look at it
the institutional um stability
of germany in that time period was not
enough
to push back and there are other periods
in german history i mean that hitler
arose in arizona in 1913
he doesn't get anywhere because
germany's institutional uh
power is enough to simply quash that
it's the fact that germany was unstable
anyway
that prevented a united front that would
have kept radicalism
from getting out of hand does that make
sense yes absolutely
a tricky question on this just to
stay in this a little longer because i'm
not sure how to think about it
is the world war ii versus the holocaust
when we we were talking just now about
the way that history unrolls itself and
could hitler have been stopped
and i i don't quite know what to think
about
hitler without the holocaust and perhaps
in his thinking how essential
the anti-semitism and the hatred of jews
was it feels to me
that i mean i don't know we were just
talking about where did he pick up his
hatred
of the jewish people there's uh there's
stories in vienna and so on
that it almost is picking up the
idea of anti-semitism as a really useful
tool
as opposed to actually believing it in
his core
do you think world war ii as it turned
out and hitler's
as he turned out would be possible
without
anti-semitism could we have avoided the
holocaust
or was it an integral part of
the ideology of fascism and the nazis
not an integral part of fascism because
mussolini really i mean
mussolini did it to please hitler but it
wasn't an integral part
what's interesting to me is that that's
the big anomaly in the whole question
because
anti-semitism didn't need to be a part
of this at all
right hitler had a conspiratorial view
of the world
he was a believer that the jews
controlled things right the jews were
responsible for both
bolshevism on one side and capitalism on
the other they ruled the banks i mean
the united states was a jewifide country
right
uh bolshevism was was a a a jewifide
sort of a a political in other words he
saw jews everywhere and he had that line
about if the jews of europe
force another war to germany they'll pay
the price or whatever but then you have
to believe that they're capable of that
that the holocaust is a weird weird
sidebar to the whole thing and here's
what i've always found
interesting it's a sidebar that weakened
germany
because look at the first world war jews
fought for germany right
who was the most important and this is a
very arguable point but it's just the
first one that pops into my head
who was the most important jewish figure
that would have maybe been on the german
side had the germans had a
non-anti-semitic
well listen that whole part of the style
yes it was einstein but the whole
i should point out to say germany or
europe or russia or any of those things
were not
anti-semitic is to do injustice to
history right pogroms everywhere i mean
yes that is it's standard operating
procedure
what what you see in the hitlerian era
is an absolute huge spike
right because the government has a
conspiracy theory that the jews have
it's funny because hitler both thought
of them as weak and super powerful at
the same time right and
and as an outsider people that we can
join the whole idea of the blood and how
that connects to darwinism and and
all that sort of stuff is just weird
right a real outlier
but einstein let's just play with
einstein
if there's no anti-semitism in germany
or or none above the normal level right
um the baseline level um does einstein
leave
along with all the other uh jewish
scientists and
i mean and what does germany have as as
increased technological
and intellectual capacity if they stay
right it's something that actually
weakened that state it's it's a tragic
flaw
in in the hitlerian worldview but it was
so
and and i don't let me you had mentioned
earlier like maybe it was
not integral to his character maybe it
was a wonderful tool for power
i don't think so somewhere along the
line and really
not at the beginning this guy became
absolutely obsessed
with this with a conspiracy theory and
jews and and and he surrounded himself
uh with people and theorists i'm going
to use that word
really really sort of loosely who
believed this too and so you have a
cabal of people who are reinforcing
this idea that the jews control the
world that inter he called it
international jewry was a huge part of
the problem and that because of that
they deserved to be punished they were
an enemy within
all these kinds of things it's a it's a
nutty conspiracy theory
that the government of one of the most i
mean the big thing with germany was
culture right they were
they were they were a leading figure in
in culture and philosophy and all these
kinds of things and that they could be
overtaken with this wildly wickedly
weird conspiracy theory and that it
would actually determine things
i mean hitler was taking vast amounts of
german resources
and using it to wipe out this race when
he needed them for all kinds of other
things to fight a war of annihilation so
that is the weirdest part of of the
whole nazi
phenomenon it's the the darkest possible
silver lining to think about is that the
holocaust
may have been in the hatred of the
jewish people may have been the thing
that avoided
germany getting the nuclear weapons
first
and is it isn't that a wonderful
historical ironic twist that if it
weren't so
overlaid with tragedy a thousand years
from now will be seen as something
really kind of funny well that's
that's true it's fascinating to think as
you've talked
so the seeds of his own destruction
right the tragic flaw
and my hope is this is a discussion i
have with my dad
as a physicist
is that evil
inherently contains with it that kind of
incompetence
so my dad's
discussions he's a physicist and
engineer his belief
is that at this time in our history the
reason we haven't had nuclear
like uh terrorist uh
blow up a nuclear weapon somewhere in
the world
is that the kind of people that would be
terrorists
are simply not competent enough at their
job
of being destructive so like there's a
kind of
if you plot it the more evil you are
the less able you are and by evil i mean
purely just like we said uh if we were
to consider the hatred of jewish people
as evil
because it's sort of detached from
reality it's like like
just this pure hatred of something
that's
grounded on things you know conspiracy
theories
if that's evil then the more you sell
yourself the more you give in to these
conspiracy theories
the less capable you are at actually
engineering
which is very difficult engineering
nuclear weapons and effectively
deploying them
so that's the that's a hopeful message
that the
destructive people in this world are by
their world view incompetent in creating
the ultimate destruction i don't agree
with that
oh boy i straight up don't agree with
that so why are we still here
why haven't we destroyed ourselves why
haven't the terrorists
blow it's been many decades why haven't
we destroyed ourselves to this point
well
it's when you say it's been many decades
many day that's like saying
in the in the life of a 150 year old
person
uh we've been doing well for a year the
problem the problem with all these kinds
of equations and it was bertrand russell
right the philosopher who said so
uh he said it was it's unreasonable to
expect a man
to walk on a tightrope for 50 years
i mean the the the problem is is that
this is a long game
and let's remember that up until
relatively recently what would you say
30 years ago
it the nuclear weapons in the world were
really tightly controlled that was one
of the real dangers in the fall of the
soviet union remember the
the um the worry that that all of a
sudden you were going to have
bankrupt former soviet republics selling
nuclear weapons to terrorists and
whatnot
i would suggest and and here's another
problem is that when we call these
terrorists evil it's easy for an
american for example
to say that osama bin laden is evil easy
for me to say that
but one man's terrorist is another man's
freedom fighter as the saying goes and
to other people he's not
what osama bin laden did and the people
that worked with him
we would call evil genius the idea of
hijacking planes and flying them into
the buildings like that and that he
could pull that off
and that still boggles my mind i'm still
it's funny i'm still stunned by that and
yet i
you know the idea here's the funny part
and i don't i i hesitate to talk about
this because i don't want to give anyone
ideas
right but you don't need nuclear weapons
to do incredibly grave amounts of danger
yes
really i mean what one can of gasoline
and a bic lighter can do in the right
place and the right time
and over and over and over again
can bring down societies this is the
argument behind
the importance of the stability that a
nation-state provides
so when we went in and took out saddam
hussein
one of the great counter-arguments from
some of the people who said this is a
really stupid thing to do
is that saddam hussein was the greatest
anti-terror weapon in that region that
you could have because they were a
threat to him
so he took that and he did it in a way
that was much more repressive than we
would ever be
right and this is the old line about why
we supported
um uh right-wing death squad countries
because they were taking out people
that would inevitably be a problem for
us if they didn't and they
they were able to do it in a way we
would never be able to do supposedly
we're
pretty good at that stuff you know just
like the soviet union was behind the
scenes and underneath the radar
but the idea that the stability created
by
powerful and strong centralized
leadership allowed them
it's almost like outsourcing anti-terror
activities allowed them to
for their own reasons i mean you see the
same thing in the syria situation with
the assads i mean
you can't have an isis in that area
because that's a threat to the assad
government who will take care of that
for you
and then that helps us by not having an
isis so um
i would suggest one that the game is
still on on whether or not these people
get nuclear weapons
uh in their hands i would suggest they
don't need them
to achieve their goals really uh the the
the crazy thing is if you start thinking
like the joker in batman
the the terrorist ideas it's funny i
guess i would be a great terrorist
because i'm just full of those ideas oh
you could do this it's scary to think of
how vulnerable we are
but the whole point is that you as the
joker
wouldn't do the terrorist actions that's
the
that's the theory that's so hopeful to
me with my dad
is that all the ideas your ability to
generate good ideas
what forget nuclear weapons how you can
disrupt the power grid how you can
disrupt
the attack our psychology uh
attack like with a can of gasoline like
you said somehow disrupt the american
system of
ideas like
that coming up with good ideas there
are we saying evil people can't come up
with evil genius ideas that's what i'm
saying
we have this hollywood story i don't
think history backs that up
i mean i think you can say with the
nuclear weapons it does but only because
they're so recent
yeah but i mean evil genius i mean
that's almost proverbial
but that's okay so to push back for the
fun of it or
i don't i don't mean to i don't want you
to leave this with a t in a terrible
mood because
i push back on every hopeful idea but i
tend to be a little cynical about that
stuff
but but that goes to the the definition
of evil i think because
i'm not so sure human history has a lot
of
evil people being competent i do believe
that they mostly like in order to be
good
at doing what may be perceived as evil
you have to be able to construct an
ideology
around which you truly believe when you
look in the mirror
by yourself that you're doing good for
the world
and it's difficult to construct an
ideology
where destroying the lives of millions
or disrupting the american system
i'm already contradicting myself as i'm
saying i'm gonna say people have done
this already yes
so i but but then it's the the question
of like
about aliens with the
the uh idea that
if the aliens are all out there why
haven't they visited us
the same question if it's so
easy to be evil not easy if it's
possible to be evil
why haven't we destroyed ourselves and
your statement is
from the context of history the game is
still
on and it's just been a few years
since we've found the tools to destroy
ourselves and
one of the challenges of our modern time
we don't often think about this pandemic
kind of revealed
is how soft we've gotten in terms of our
deep dependence on the system so
somebody mentioned to me you know what
happens if power goes out
for a day what happens if power goes out
for
a month oh for example the person that
mentioned this was a
berkeley faculty uh that i was talking
with
he's an astronomer who's observing solar
flares
and it's very possible that a solar
flare
they happen all the time to different
degrees i've got your cell phones
yeah to knock out the power grid for
months so like
you know just as a thought experiment
what happens if just power goes out for
a week in this country this is like the
e and the
electromagnetic magnetic pulses and the
nuclear weapons and all those kinds of
things yeah
but maybe that's an act of nature yes
and even just the act of nature will
reveal like a little fragility
the fragility of it all and then the
evil can emerge i mean the kind of
things that might happen when power goes
out
especially during a divisive time well
you won't have food
at baseline level that would mean that
the
the uh the entire supplies chain begins
to break down
and then you have desperation and
desperation opens the door to everything
can ask a dark question as opposed to
the other things we've been talking
about
there's there's always a thread a
hopeful message i think it'll be a
hopeful message on this one too you may
have the wrong guess
um if you were to bet money
on the way that human civilization
destroys itself
or it collapses in some way that
is where the result would be
unrecognizable to us
as anything akin to progress
what would you say is it nuclear weapons
is it some societal breakdown through
just more traditional kinds of war
is it engineered pandemics
nanotechnology is it artificial
intelligence
is it something we can't even expect yet
do you have a sense of how we humans
will destroy ourselves
or might we live forever i think what
what governs my view of this thing is
is the ability for us to focus ourselves
collectively right and that gives me the
choice of looking at this and saying
what are the odds we will do
x versus y right um so go look at the 62
cuban missile crisis where uh we
looked at the potential of nuclear war
and we stared right in the face of that
to me i consider that to be you want to
talk about a hopeful moment
that's one of the rare times in our
history where i think the odds
were overwhelmingly that there would be
a nuclear war
and uh i'm not the super kennedy
worshiper that you know i grew up in an
era where he was
especially amongst people in the
democratic party he was almost worshiped
and i was never that guy but i will say
something
john f kennedy by himself um
probably made decisions that saved a
hundred million or more lives
because everyone around him thought he
should be
taking the road that would have led to
those deaths and to push back against
that
is when you look at it now i mean again
if you were a betting person you would
have bet against that
and that's rare right um so
so when we talk about how the world will
end um
the fact that one person actually had
that
in their hands meant that it wasn't a
collective decision
it gave remember i said i trust people
on an individual level but when we get
together we're more like a herd and we
devolve down to the lowest common
denominator
that was something where the higher uh
ethical
ideas of a single human being could come
into play and make the decisions that
that influence the events but when we
have to act
collectively i get a lot more
pessimistic so take
what we're doing to the planet and we
talk about it always now in terms of
climate change which i think is far too
narrow
uh look at you know and and i i always
get very
frustrated when we talk about these
arguments about is it happening is it
human
just look at the trash forget forget
climb it for a second
we're destroying the planet because
we're not taking care of it and because
what it would do to take care of it
would require collective sacrifices
that would require enough of us to say
okay
and and we can't get enough of us to say
okay
because too many people have to be on
board it's not john f kennedy making one
decision from one man
we have to have 85 percent of us or
something around the world
not just you can't say we're going to
stop uh uh doing damage to the to the
to the world here in the united states
if china does it right so the amount of
people that have to get on board that
train
is hard you get pessimistic hoping for
those kinds of shifts
unless it's right you know krypton's
about to explode
we have and so i think if you're talking
about a gambling man's view of this
that that's got to be the odds on
favorite because it requires such a
unanim
i mean and the systems maybe aren't even
in place right the fact that we would
need
intergovernmental bodies that are
completely discredited now on board and
you would have to subvert uh the
national interests of nation states i
mean the
the amount of things that have to go
right
in a short period of time we don't have
600 years to figure this out right
so to me that that looks like the most
likely just because the things we would
have to do to avoid it seem the most
unlikely does that make sense yes
absolutely
i i believe call me naive in
just like you said with the individual i
believe
that charismatic leaders individual
leaders will save us
like this what if you don't get them all
at the same time what if you get a
charismatic leader in one country but
under or what if you get a charismatic
leader in a country that doesn't really
matter that much
well it's a ripple effect so it starts
with one leader and
their charisma inspires other leaders
like so
it's uh it's like one ant queen steps up
and then the rest of the ant starts
behaving
and then there's like little other
spikes of leaders that emerge
and then that's where collaboration
emerges i tend to believe that like
when you heat up the system and [ __ ]
starts getting
really chaotic then
the leader whatever this collective
intelligence that we've developed
the leader will emerge like do you think
there's just as much of a chance though
that the leader would emerge and say the
jews are the people who did all this
right
you know what i'm saying is that the
idea that they would come up you have a
charismatic leader and he's going to
come up with the rights or she
is going to come up with the right
solution as opposed to totally
coming up with the wrong solution i mean
i guess what i'm saying is
you could be right but a lot of things
have to go the right way
but my intuition about the evolutionary
process that led to the creation of
human
intelligence and consciousness on earth
results in the the power of
like if we think of it just the love in
the system versus the hate in the system
that the love is greater the human
the the the human kindness
potential in the system is greater than
the human
uh hatred potential and so the leader
that is in the time when it's needed
the leader that inspires love
and kindness will is more likely to
emerge
and will have more power so you have the
hitlers of the world that
emerge but they're actually in the grand
scheme of history are not that impactful
so it's it's weird to say but not that
many people died in world war ii
if you look at the the the the full
range of human history uh you know it's
uh
up to 100 million whatever that is with
natural pandemics too you can have those
kinds of numbers but it's still
a percentage i forget what the
percentage is maybe three five percent
of the human population on earth maybe
it's a little bit focused on a different
region
but it's not destructive to the entirety
of human civilization
so the i believe that the
the charismatic leaders when time is
needed
that do good for the world in uh
the broader sense of good are more
likely to emerge than the ones that say
kill all the jews i it's it's possible
though and this is just you know i've
thought about this all of 30 seconds but
i mean uh
it it it's we're betting money here on
the on the 21st century who's going to
win
i think maybe uh you've divided this
into too much of a black and white
dichotomy
this love and good on one side and this
evil on another let me throw
something that might be more in the
center of that linear
uh a balancing act self-interest
which may or may not be good you know
good the good version of it we call
enlightened self-interest right
the bad version of it we call
selfishness
but self-interest to me seems like
something more likely to
impact the outcome than either love on
one side or evil on the other
simply a question of what's good for me
or what's good for my country
or what's good from my point of view or
what's good for my business
i mean if you tell me um and
maybe i i'm a coal miner or maybe i own
a coal mine
if you say to me we have to stop using
coal because it's hurting the earth
i have a hard time disentangling
that greater good question from my
right now good feeding my family
question right
so i think i think maybe it's going to
be a much more banal
thing than good and evil much more a
question of
we're not all going to decide at the
same time
that the interests that we have are
aligned
does that make sense yeah totally but i
mean i've looked at ayn rand and
objectivism and kind of really thought
like how bad or good can things go when
everybody's acting selfishly
but i think we're just talking two ants
here with microphones
talking about two seconds
but like the the question is
when they when this spreads so what what
is
what do i mean by love and kindness
i think it's human flourishing on earth
and throughout the cosmos
it feels like whatever the engine that
drives human beings
is more likely to result in human
flourishing
and people like hitler are not good for
human flourishing
so that's what i mean by good is they is
is there's a i mean maybe it's an
intuition that
kindness is an evolutionary advantage
i hate those terms i hate to reduce
stuff to the
evolutionary biology always but it just
seems like for us to multiply
throughout the universe it's good to be
kind to each other
and those leaders will always emerge to
save us
from the hitlers of the world that want
to kind of burn the thing down with a
flamethrower
that's the intuition but let's talk
about you you brought up evolution
several times
let me let me play with that for a
minute um
i think going back to animal times we
are conditioned
to deal with overwhelming threats right
in front of us so i have quite a bit of
faith
in humanity when it comes to impending
doom
right outside our door uh if krypton's
about to explode i think humanity can r
rouse themselves to great and would give
power to the people who needed it and be
willing to make the sacrifices
but that's what makes i think the the
pollution slash climate change slash
you know screwing up your environment um
uh threats so particularly insidious
is it happens slowly right it defies
fight and flight mechanisms it defies
the natural ability we have to deal with
the threat that's
right on top of us and it requires an
amount of foresight that while some
people would would be fine with that
most people are too worried and
understandably i think too worried
about today's threat rather than next
generations threat or whatever it might
be
so i mean when we talk about when you
had said what do you think the greatest
threat is
i think with nuclear weapons i think
could we have a nuclear war we darn
right could but i i think that there's
enough
of of inertia we're against that because
people
understand instinctively if i decide to
launch this attack against china and i'm
india
we're going to have 50 million dead
people tomorrow whereas if you say
we're gonna have a whole planet of dead
people in three generations if we don't
start now
i think the evolutionary uh
way that we have have evolved mitigates
maybe against that in other words
i think i would be pleasantly surprised
if we could pull that off does that make
sense
totally i don't mean to be like the i'm
the i'm the scripting doom
it's fun that way i think we're both uh
maybe i'm over the top on the left
maybe i'm over the top on the doom so it
makes
it makes for a fun chat i think so one
one guy that i've talked to several
times
who's slowly becoming a friend is a guy
named elon musk
he's a big fan of hardcore history
uh especially genghis khan uh series of
episodes but
really all of it him and his uh his
girlfriend grimes listen to it which is
i know what you like yeah you know elon
okay awesome so that's like relationship
goals
uh like listen to hardcore history on
the weekend with your loved one
okay uh so let me if i were to look at
the guy
from a perspective of human history it
feels like
he will be a little speck that's
remembered
oh absolutely you think about like the
people what will
we remember from our time who are the
people will remember
whether it's the the hitler's or the
einsteins
who's going to be it's hard to predict
when you're in it
but it seems like elon would be one of
those people remembered and if i were to
guess what he's remembered for
it's the work he's doing with spacex and
potentially being
the person that we don't know but the
being the person
who launched a new era of space
exploration
if we look you know centuries from now
if we are successful as human beings
surviving long enough
to venture out into the you know october
the stars
it's weird to ask you this i don't know
what your opinions are
but do you think humans will be a
multi-planetary species
in the arc long arc of history do you
think elon will be successful in his
dream
and he doesn't he doesn't shy away from
saying it this way right
he really wants us to colonize
mars first and then colonize other
earth-like planets in other solar
systems throughout the galaxy
do you have a hope that we humans will
venture out towards the stars
so here's the thing and this actually
again dovetails do what we were talking
about earlier
i actually first of all
i toured spacex and it is when you you
it's hard to get your mind around
because he's doing what it took
governments to do before yes okay so so
it's incredible that we're watching
individual companies and stuff doing
this
doing it faster and cheaper yeah well
and and and and pushing the envelope
right faster than the governments at the
time we're moving it's it's
it really is i mean there's a lot of
people who i i think
who think elon is is overrated and
you have no idea right when you go see
it you have no idea
but that's actually not what i'm most
impressed with um
it's tesla i'm most impressed with and
the reason why is because
in my mind we just talked about what i
think is the greatest threat
the environmental stuff and i talked
about our inability maybe all at the
same time
to be willing to sacrifice our
self-interests
in order for the for the goal and i
don't want to put words in elon's mouth
so you can you can talk to him if you
want to but in my mind
what he's done is recognize that problem
and instead of building a car that's a
piece of crap but you know it's good for
the environment so you should drive it
he's trying to create a car
that if you're only motivated by your
self-interest
you'll buy it anyway and it will help
the environment and help us transition
away from one of the main causes
of damage i mean one of the things this
pandemic
and the shutdown around the world has
done is show us
how amazingly quickly the earth can
actually rejuvenate we're seeing clear
skies in places species come
and you would have thought it would have
taken decades for some of this stuff
so what if to name just one major
pollution source
we didn't have the pollution caused by
automobiles right
and and if if you had said to me dan
what do you think the odds of us
transitioning away from that were 10
years ago i would have said well people
aren't going to do it because it's
inefficient it's this it's that nobody
wants people
but what if you created the vehicle that
was superior in every way so that if you
were just a self-oriented consumer
you'd buy it because you wanted that car
that's the best way to get around that
problem of people not wanting to i think
he's
identified that and as he's told me
before
you know when the last time a car
company was created that actually you
know
blah blah blah he's right and so i
happen to feel that even though he's
pushing the envelope on the space thing
i think somebody else would have done
that someday
i'm not sure because of the various
things he's mentioned
how difficult it is to start i'm not
sure that the industries that create
vehicles for us
would have gone where he's going to lead
them
if he didn't force them there through
consumer demand by making a better car
that people want it anyway
they'll follow they'll copy they'll do
all those things
and yet who was going to do that so
i hope he doesn't hate me for saying
this but i happen to think the tesla
idea
may alleviate some of the need to get
off this planet because the planet's
being destroyed
right and we're going to colonize mars
probably anyway if we live long enough
and i think the tesla idea not just
elon's version but ones that follow from
other people
is the best chance of making sure we're
around long enough to see mars colonized
does that make sense
yeah totally and one other thing from my
perspective because i'm now starting a
company
i think the interesting thing about elon
is he serves as a beacon
of hope like pragmatically speaking
for people that sort of push back on our
doom conversation from earlier
that a single individual could
build something that
allows us as self-interested individuals
to gather together in a collective way
to actually alleviate some of the
dangers that
face our world so like it gives me hope
as an individual that i can build
something
that can actually have impact
that counteracts the uh
the stalins and the hitlers and all the
threats that face
that human civilization faces that an
individual has that power
i i didn't believe that the individual
has that power in the
in the halls of government like i don't
feel like any one presidential candidate
can
rise up and help the world unite the
world
it feels like from everything i've seen
in
and you're right with tesla it can bring
the world together
to do good that's a really powerful
mechanism of
you know whatever you say about
capitalism that you can build companies
that start you know it starts with a
single individual of course there's a
collective that
that grows around that but the
leadership of a single individual
their ideas their dreams their vision
can catalyze something that takes over
the world
and does good for the entire world but
if i think but again i i think
the genius of the idea is that it
doesn't require us
to go head-to-head with human nature
right
he he's he's actually built human nature
into the idea by basically saying i'm
not asking you to be
uh an environmental activist i'm not
asking you to sacrifice to make
i'm gonna sell you a car you're going to
like better and by buying it you'll help
the environment
that takes into account our foibles as a
species
and actually leverages that to work for
the greater good and that's the sort of
thing that does
turn off my little doom caster cynicism
thing a little bit because
you're actually hitting us where we live
right you're you're you're not
you can take somebody who doesn't even
believe the environment's a problem but
they want a tesla so they're
inadvertently
helping anyway i think that's the genius
of the idea
yeah and i'm telling you that's one way
to make love much more efficient
mechanism of change
than uh hate making it in your
self-interest
just creating a product that uh
least to more love than uh than hate
you're gonna want to love your neighbor
because you're gonna make a fortune
okay there you go that's why he's right
i'm on board
that's why elon said love is the answer
that's i think uh
exactly what he meant okay let's
try something difficult uh you've uh
recorded
an episode of steering into the iceberg
on your common sense program yeah that
has started a lot of conversations
it's quite moving it was quite haunting
got me a lot of angry emails
really of course i did something i
haven't done in 30 years i endorsed a
political candidate from one of the two
main parties and there were a lot of
disillusioned people because of that i
guess i didn't hear it as an endorsement
i just heard it as a
the similar flavor of conversation as
you have in in
hardcore history it's almost the
speaking about modern times
in the same voice as you speak about
when you talk about history
so it was just a a little bit of a
haunting
view of the world today
i know we were just wearing our doom
doom
let me put that right back on are you no
the
the i like the term doom caster uh
is is there is there um
how do we get love to win what's the way
out of this
is there some hopeful
line that we can walk to uh
to avoid something and i hate to use the
terminology but
something that looks like a civil war
not necessarily a war of force but a
a division to a level where it doesn't
any longer feel like a united
states of america with an emphasis on
united
is is there a way out i read a book
a while back i want to say george
friedman the stratfor
guy wrote it was something called the
next hundred years i think it was called
and i remember thinking um i didn't
agree with any of it and one of the
things i think he said in the book was
that you know the united states was
going to break up i'm going from memory
here he might not have said that at all
but something was stuck in my memory
about that i remember thinking
um but i i think some of the arguments
were connected to
the differences that we had and the fact
that those differences are being
exploited so
we talked about media earlier in the
lack of truth and everything we have
a media climate that is incentivized
to take the wedges in our society and
make them
wider and there's no countervailing
force
to do the opposite or to help to you
know so um
there was a famous uh memo
from a group called project for a new
american century and they took it down
but the way back machine online still
has it and it happened before 9 11
spawned all kind of conspiracy theories
because it was saying
something to the effect of and i'm
really paraphrasing here but you know
that
the united states needs another pearl
harbor type event
because those galvanize a country that
without those kinds of events
periodically
is naturally geared towards pulling
itself apart
and it's those periodic events that act
as the countervailing force that
otherwise is not there
um if that's true then we are
naturally inclined towards pulling
ourselves apart
so to have a media environment
that makes money off widening those
divisions
uh which we do i mean i was in talk
radio and and it
it has those people the people that used
to scream at me because i wouldn't do it
but i mean we would have these terrible
conversations after every broadcast
where i'd be in there with the program
director and they're yelling at me about
heat
heat was the worthy create more heat
well what is heat right
heat is division right and they want the
heat not because they're political
they're not republicans or or democrats
either they're
we want listeners and we want engagement
and involvement
and because of the constructs of the
format you don't have a lot of time to
get it so you can't have me giving you
like on a podcast
an hour and a half or two hours where we
build a logical argument
and you're with me the whole way your
audience is changing every 15 minutes
so whatever points you make to create
interest and intrigue
and engagement have to be knee-jerk
right now
things they told me once that the
audience has to know where you stand on
every single issue within five minutes
of turning on your show
in other words you have to be part of a
of a linear
set of political beliefs so that if you
feel a
about subject a then you must feel d
about subject d
and i don't even need to hear your
opinion on it because if you feel that
way about a you're going to feel that
way about d
this is a system that is designed to
pull us apart for
profit but not because they want to pull
us apart
right it's a byproduct of the prophet
that's one little example of of
50 examples in our society that work in
that same
fashion so what that project for a new
american century
document was saying is that we're
naturally inclined
towards disunity and without things to
occasionally
ratchet the unity back up again so that
we can start from the baseline again and
then pull ourselves apart till the next
pearl harbor that you'll pull yourself
apart which i think was
i think that's what the george friedman
book was saying that i disagreed with so
much at the time
um so in answer to your question about
civil wars
we can't have the same kind of civil war
because we don't have a geographical
division that's as clear-cut as the one
we had before right you had a basically
north-south line and some border states
it was set up for that kind of a split
now we're divided within communities
within families
within gerrymandered voting districts
and precincts right
so you can't disengage we're stuck with
each other so if there's a civil war now
for lack of a better word what it might
seem like
is the late 1960s early 1970s where you
had
the bombings and you know let's call it
domestic terrorism and things like that
because that
that would seem to be something that
once again you don't even need a large
chunk of the country pulling apart ten
percent of people who think
it's it's the end times can do the
damage just like we talked about
terrorism before
and a can of gas and a big lighter i've
lived in a bunch of places and i won't
give anybody ideas where a can of gas in
a bic lighter
would take a thousand houses down before
you could blink
yeah right um that terrorist doesn't
have to be
from the middle east doesn't have to
have some sort of a fundamentalist
religious agenda
it could just be somebody really pissed
off about the election results
so once again if we're playing an odds
game here
everybody has to behave for this to work
right
only a few people have to misbehave for
this thing to go sideways and remember
for every action there is an equal and
opposite reaction
so you don't even have to have those
people doing all these things all they
have to do is start
retribution cycle and there's an
escalation yes and it go
and it creates a momentum of its own
which leads fundamentally if you follow
the chain of events down there
to some form of dictatorial government
as the only way to
create stability right you want to
destroy the republic and have a dictator
that's how you do and there are
parallels to nazi germany the burning of
the reichstag that you know blah blah
blah
i'm the doom caster again all right well
and some of it could be manufactured
by the those seeking authoritarian power
absolutely
like the reichstag fire was or the
polish soldiers that fired over the
border before the invasion in 1939
uh to fight the uh the devil's advocate
was an angel's advocate
uh i would say just as our conversation
about elon
it feels like individuals have power to
unite us
to to be that force of unity so
uh you mentioned the media i think
you're one of the
great podcasters in history joe rogan is
a
like a long form whatever it's not
podcasting it's actually
whatever the very infrequent is what it
is no matter what it is
but the basic process of it is you go
deep and you stay deep
and the listener stays with you for a
long time so
i i'm just looking at the numbers like
we're almost three hours in
and i from previous episodes i can tell
you that
about 300 000 people are still listening
to the sound of our voice three hours in
so usually 300 to 500 000 people listen
and they too congratulations by the way
that's wonderful
joe rogan is what like 10 times that and
so
he has power
to unite uh you have power to unite
there's a few
people with voices that it feels like
they have power to unite
even if you if you quote unquote endorse
a candidate and so on
there's still it feels to me that
speaking of i don't want to keep saying
love but it's
love and maybe unity more practically
speaking
that like sanity that
like respect for those you don't agree
with or don't
understand uh so
empathy well just a few voices of those
can help us avoid the really importantly
not avoid the singular events like you
said of somebody starting a fire and so
on
but avoid the escalation of it
the preparedness of the populace to
escalate
those events to yeah to to turn a
singular event
in a single riot or a shooting or
like even something much more dramatic
than that to turn that into something
that creates like ripples that grow
as opposed to ripples that fade away and
so like
i would like to put responsibility on
somebody like you
and uh on me in some small way and joe
being cognizant of the fact
that a lot of very destructive things
might happen in november
and a few voices can save us is the
feeling i have
not by saying we should vote for or any
of that kind of stuff
but really by being the the voice of
calm that like calms
the the seas from
or whatever the analogy is from boiling
up
because i i truly am worried about
this is the first time this year when i
i sometimes i somehow have felt that the
american project will go on forever
that when i came to this country i just
believed and i think i'm young but like
you know i have a dream of creating a
company
that will do a lot of good for the world
and
i thought that america is the beacon of
hope for the world
and the ideas of freedom but also the
idea of empowering companies that can do
some good for the world
and i'm just worried about this america
that filled me a kid that came from
our family came from nothing and from
you know russia as it was soviet union
as it was to be
able to do anything in this new country
i'm just worried about it and it feels
like a few people
can still keep this project going
like people like elon people like joe
uh is there
do you have a bit of that hope i'm
watching this experiment
with social media right now and i don't
even mean social media really expand
that out to um
i mean i feel like we're all guinea pigs
right now watching you know i have
two kids and and just watching and
there's a three year space between the
two of them one's 18 the other is 15.
and just you know in when i was a kid a
person who was 18 and 15 would not be
that different
just three years difference more
maturity but their life experiences you
would easily classify those two people
as being in the same generation
now because of the speed of
technological change
there is a vast difference between my 18
year old and my 15 year old
and not in a maturity question just in
what apps they use
how they relate to each other how they
deal with their peers
uh their social skills all those kinds
of things where you turn around and go
this is uncharted territory we've never
been here so it's going to be
interesting to see what effect that has
on society now as that relates to your
question
the most upsetting part about all that
is reading how people treat each other
online and you know there's lots of
theories about this the fact
that some of it is just for trolling
laughs that some of it is just people
are not
interacting face to face so they feel
free to treat each other that way
um and i of course i'm trying to figure
out
how how if this is how we have
always been as people right we've always
been this way but we've never had the
means to post our feelings
publicly about it or if the environment
and the social media and everything else
has provided a
change and changed us into something
else
um either way when one reads
how we treat one another and the
horrible things we say about one another
online
which seems like it shouldn't be that
big of deal they're just
word but they have a cumulative effect i
mean when you
uh i was reading um meghan markle
who i don't know a lot about because
it's it's too much of the pop side of
culture for me to pay
but i read a story the other day where
she was talking about the abuse she took
online
and how incredibly overwhelming it was
and how
many people were doing it and you think
to yourself
okay this is something that people who
are in positions of what you were
discussing earlier never had to deal
with
let me ask you something and boy this is
the ultimate doom caster thing of all
time to say
when you think of historical figures
that push
things like love and
peace and um and and creating bridges
between
enemies when you think of how what
happened to those
people first of all they're very
dangerous every society in the world has
a better time easier time dealing with
violence and things like that than they
do
non-violence non-violence is really
difficult for governments to deal with
for example
what happens to gandhi and jesus and
martin luther king and you think about
all those people right
when they're that day it's it's ironic
isn't it that these people who push for
peaceful solutions are so often killed
but it's because they're effective and
when they're
killed the effectiveness is diminished
why are they killed because they're
effective and and the only way to stop
them is to eliminate them because
they're
charismatic leaders who don't come
around every day and if you eliminate
them from the scene
the odds are you're not going to get
another one for a while i guess what i'm
saying is the very things you're talking
about which would have the effect you
think it would right they would
destabilize
systems in a way that most of us would
consider positive
but those systems have a way of
protecting themselves
right and and so i i feel like
history shows see history is pretty
pessimistic i think by and large um
if only because we can find so many
examples that just sound passive
but i feel like people who are dangerous
to the way
things are tend to be removed
yes but there's two things to say i feel
like you're right
that history i feel like
the ripples that love leaves in history
are less obvious to detect but are
actually more
transformational like well one could
make a case about i mean if you want to
talk about the
the long-term value of a jesus a gandhi
yeah yes those people's ripples are
still
affecting people today i agree and
that's you feel those ripples through
the general
improvement of the quality of life that
we see in
throughout the generations like you feel
the ripples
i'll go along with you on that okay but
i would even if that's not true
now i tend to believe
that and by the way the the company that
i'm
working on is a competitor is exactly
attacking this which is
a competitor to twitter i think i can
build a better twitter as a first step
there's a longer story in there i think
a three-year-old child could build it
better and that this is not to denigrate
you
i'm sure yours would be better than a
three-year-old but twitter is so and
listen
facebook to their they're really awful
platforms for intellectual discussion
and meaningful discussion
but and i'm on it so let me just say i'm
part of the problem we're new to this so
it's not it wasn't obvious at the time
how to do it it's
now you agree and now a three-year-old
can i do
i i tend to believe that we live in a
time
where the tools that people that are
interested
in providing love like the weapons
of love are much more powerful
so like the one nice thing about
technology
is it allows anyone to build a company
that's more powerful than any government
so that could be very destructive
but it could be also very positive
and that's i tend to believe that
somebody like elon that wants to do good
for the world
somebody like me and many like me could
have
more power than any one government to
uh and by power i mean the power to
affect change
which is different from government
government and i don't mean to interrupt
you but i'll forget my train of thought
i'm getting
old but i mean how do you deal with the
fact that already governments
who are afraid of this are walling off
their own internet systems as a way to
create
firewalls simply to prevent you from
doing what you're talking about
in other words if there's an old line
that if voting really changed anything
they'd never allow
it if if love through a
modern day successor to twitter would
really do
what you wanted to do and this would
destabilize governments
do you think that governments would
would take counter measures
to squash that love before it got too
dangerous there's several answers
one first of all i don't actually to
push back on something you said earlier
i don't think love is as much of an
enemy of the state
as as one would think different states
have different views
i i think the
states want power and i don't always
think that
love is in tension with power
like i think and and
i think it's not just about love it's
about rationality it's reason
it's empathy all of those things i don't
necessarily think there always
have to be by definition in conflict
with each other
so that's one sense is i feel like
basically you can trojan horse love into
behind behind uh but you have to be good
at it this is the thing
is you have to be conscious of the way
these states think
so the fact that china banned certain
services and so on
that means the the companies weren't
eloquent
whoever the companies are weren't
actually good
at infiltrating like
i think isn't that a song like love is a
battlefield
i think it's all a cat editor yeah it's
all a game
and you have to be good at the game and
just like elon we said
you know with tesla and saving uh the
environment
i mean that's not just by getting on a
stage and saying it's important to save
the environment
is by building a product that
people can't help but love and then
convincing hollywood stars to love it
like
there's there's a game to be played okay
so let me let me build on that because i
i think there's a way to see this i
think you're right and so uh
it has to do with a story about the
1960s in the vast scheme of things the
1960s looks like a revival of
neo-romantic
ideas right uh i had a buddy of mine
several years well
two decades older than i was who was uh
in the 60s went to the protest did all
those kind of things
and we were talking about it and i was
romanticizing it and he said don't
romanticize he goes let me tell you most
of the people that went to those
protests and did all those things
all they were there was to meet girls
and have a good time and you know it was
it wasn't so
but it became
in vogue to have all in other words
let's talk about your empathy and love
you're never gonna in my opinion grab
that great mass of people that are only
in it for them
they're interested in whatever but if
meeting
girls for a young teenage guy requires
you to
feign empathy requires you to read
deeper subjects because that's what
people are into
you can almost as a silly way to be
trendy you could make maybe
empathy trendy love trendy solutions
that
that are the opposite of that um the
kind of things that people
inherently will not put up with you in
other words
the possibility exists to change the
zeitgeist
yes and reorient it in a way that even
if most of the people aren't serious
about it
the results are the same does that make
sense absolutely
okay okay so we've found a meeting of
the month yeah
yeah exactly creating creating
incentives that uh
that encourage the best and the most
beautiful
aspects of feminism it all boils down to
meeting girls and boys
once again you're getting to the bottom
of the evolutionary motivations and
you're always on safe ground when you do
that yeah
that's a little difficult for me of uh
you know and i'm sure it's actually
difficult for you
to to listen to me say complimenting you
but
uh it's not good it's difficult for both
of us okay
so but uh you know you and i as i
mentioned to you i think off mike
been friends for a long time it's just
been one way
so like i've been away now it's two way
is to right now so like that's the
beauty of
podcasting you know i mean now just been
fortunate enough
with this particular podcast that i see
in people's eyes when they meet me
that they've been friends with me for
for for a few years now
and and we become fast friends actually
after we start talking yeah but it's one
way
in the vet in that first moment
uh you know like there's something about
your especially hardcore history that
uh you know i do some crazy challenges
and running and stuff
i remember in particular probably don't
have time one of my favorite episodes
the
painfultainment one some people hate
that episode
because it's too real
it's my darkest one we wanted to set a
baseline that's the baseline
but i remember listening to that and
when i ran uh
22 miles for me that was the long
distance
yeah and uh it just pulls you in and
there there's something
so powerful about this particular
creation that's bigger than you actually
that you've created
it's kind of interesting i think
anything that is successful like that
like elon stuff too it becomes bigger
than you and that's
that's what you're hoping for right yeah
absolutely didn't mean to interrupt you
i apologize
i guess one a question i have if you
like look in the mirror but you also
look at me
what advice would you give to yourself
and to me and to other podcasters maybe
to joe rogan
about this journey that we're on i feel
like it's something
special i'm not sure exactly what's
happening but it feels like podcasting
is special
what advice and i'm relatively new to it
what advice do you have for for people
that are carrying this flame
and traveling this journey well
i'm often asked for advice by new
podcasters people just starting out and
so i have sort of a
a tried and true list of uh
do's and don'ts and and but i don't have
um advice or suggestions for you
or for joe joe doesn't need anything
from me joe's figured it out right i
mean he hasn't yet he's still
a confused kid curious about the world
that's but that's the genius of it
that's what makes it work
right that's what that's what joe's
brand is right
um i guess what i'm saying is by the
time you reach the stage that you're at
or joe's at or they don't need they have
figured this out the people that
sometimes need help are brand new people
trying to figure out what do i do with
my first show and
how do i talk to them and and i have
standard answers for that
but you found your niche i mean you
don't need me to tell you
what to do as a matter of fact i might
ask you questions about how you do what
you do
right well there's uh i guess there's
specific things like we were uh talking
offline about monetization
that's a fascinating one very difficult
as an independent yeah and uh one of the
things that joe
is facing with um i don't know if you're
paying attention but
he joined spotify with a 100 million
dollar deal
before going exclusive on their platform
the idea of exclusivity that one i don't
give a damn about money personally
but i'm single so and i i like living in
a shitty place so
i i enjoy it so i guess makes it easier
you get the freedom right
now you know yeah freedom materials is
slate not saving for anybody's college
exactly yeah okay so uh on that point
but i also
okay maybe it's romanticization but i
feel like podcasting is pirate radio
and when i first heard about spotify
partnering up with joe i was like you
know [ __ ] the man
i i said i i even i drafted a few tweets
and so on just like
attacking spotify then i'd calm myself
down
that you can't lock up the special thing
we have
but then i realized that maybe
that these are vehicles for just
reaching more people
and actually respecting podcasters more
and so on
so that's what i mean by it's unclear
what the journey is
because uh you also serve as beacon for
now there's like millions 1 million plus
podcasters
i i i wonder what the journey is
do you have a sense um are you
at romantic in the same kind of way in
feeling that
because you have a roots and radio too
do you feel that podcasting is pirate
radio
or is the spotify thing one possible
avenue
are you nervous about joe as a fan as a
friend of joe
or is this a it's a good thing for us
so my history of how i got involved in
podcasting
is interesting yes i i i was in radio
uh and then i started a company back in
the
era where the dot-com boom was happening
and everybody was being bought up and it
just seemed like a great idea right
start
um i did it with seven other six other
people
and the whole goal of the company was uh
we had we had to invent the term i'm
sure everybody
there's other places that invented it at
the same time but what we were pitching
to investors was something called
amateur content so this is before
youtube before podcasting before all
this stuff
and i my job was to be the evangelist
and i would go to these people and talk
and and sing the praises of
all the ways that amateur content was
going to be great
and i never got a bite and they all told
me the same thing this isn't going to
take off because
anybody who's good is already going to
be making money at this and i kept
saying
forget that we're talking about scale
here
if you have millions of pieces of
content being made every week
a small percentage is going to be good
no matter what right 16 year olds will
know what other 16 year old is like and
i kept pushing this nobody bit but the
podcast grew out of that because
in if you're talking about amateur
content in 1999
well then you're already where you know
you're ahead of the game in terms of
not seeing where it's going to go
financially but seeing where it's going
to go technologically
and so when we started the podcast in
2005 and it was the political one not
hardcore history
um which was an outgrowth of the old
radio show um
we didn't have any financial um ideas
we were simply trying to get our handle
on the technology and how you distribute
it to people and all that and it was
years later
that we tried to figure out okay how can
we get enough money to just support us
while
we're doing this and we and the cheap
and the easy way was just to ask
listeners to donate like a pbs kind of
model and that was
that was the original model um so then
once we started down that we figured out
other models and there's the advertising
thing and
we sell the old shows and so all these
became ways for us to support ourselves
um but as as podcasting matured
and as more operating systems develop
and
phones were developed and all these
kinds of things every one of those
developments which actually made it
easier for people to get the podcast
actually made it more complex to make
money off of them yes
so while our audience was building the
amount of time and effort we had to put
into the monetization
side began to skyrocket so to get back
to your spotify question to use just one
example there's a lot of people who are
doing similar things um in this day and
age you know we
just sell mp3 files and all you had to
have was an mp3 player it's
cheap and dirty now every time there's
an os upgrade something breaks for us
so we're having i mean my choices are at
this point to start hiring staff
more staff you know people and then be a
human resources manager
i mean the pirate radio side of this was
the pirate radio side of this because
you didn't need anybody but
you know you or you and another i mean
you could just do this lean and mean and
it's becoming hard to do it lean and
mean now so if somebody like a spotify
comes in and says hey
um we'll handle that stuff for you in
the past i would just say
f off we don't need you yeah i don't
mind and i i
definitely am not making what we could
make on this but what we would have to
do to make that
is honoris to me but it's becoming
onerous to me
day to day anyway and so if somebody
were to come in and say
hey uh we'll pick that up for you we
will not interfere with your content at
all we won't and in my case you can't
say we need a show a month because that
ain't happening right
so i mean everybody's everybody's uh
design is different
right so it doesn't you know there's not
one size fits all but i guess
as a long time pirate podcaster
um there are you know we've been looking
to partner with people but nobody's
right for us to partner with i mean
so so i'm always looking for ways
to take that side of it off my plate
because i'm not interested in that side
all i want to do
is the shows and the you know it's
really at this point
you shouldn't call yourself an artist
because some you know that's something
to be decided by other
but i mean we're trying to do art and
there's something very
satisfying in that but the part that i
can't stand is
the the increasing amount of time the
monetization
question takes upon us and so there's a
case to be made i guess is what i'm
saying
that if a partnership with some outside
firm
enhances your ability to do the art
without
disenhancing your ability to do the art
it's
um the word i'm looking for here is it's
um
it's it's enticing yes uh i don't like
big companies
um so i'm afraid of of whatever strings
might
come with that and if i'm joe rogan and
i'm talking about subjects that can make
company public companies you know a
little nervous
um i would certainly be careful but at
the same time
people who are not in this game don't
understand
the problems that literally i mean just
all the operating systems all the
podcatchers
every time some new podcatcher comes out
makes it easier to get the podcast
that's something we have to account for
on the back end
and i'm not exactly the technological
wizard of all time
so um i think it is maybe maybe the
short answer is is that as the medium
develops
it's becoming something that you have to
consider not because you want to sell
out but because you want to keep going
and it's becoming harder and harder to
be
pirate-like in this environment the
thing that convinced me
especially inside spotify is that
they understand so if you walk
into this whole thing with some
skepticism as you're saying of big
companies then then it works because
spotify understands the magic that makes
podcasting
or they appear to in part at least they
understand enough
to respect joe rogan and despite what i
don't
i don't know if you uh so there's the
internet and there's people with
opinions on the internet really
yes and they have opinions
about joe and spotify but the reality is
there's two things in private
conversation with joe and
in general there's two important things
one spotify
literally doesn't tell joe anything like
all the people that think they
the spotify somehow pushing joe in this
direction
contractuals didn't insist upon that
it's in the contract but also
you know companies have a way of even
with the contract i sure do
to be you know marketing people hey i
know we're not forcing you yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
i hate that yeah but jump with you what
you and joe are the same and
spotify is smart enough not to send a
single email of that kind
that's really smart and they leave they
leave them be
there is meetings inside spotify that
like people have read about
people complain but those meetings never
reached joe that
that never that's like company stuff and
the idea
that spotify is different than pirate
radio
the the difficult thing about podcasting
is nobody gives a damn about your
podcast
you're alone in this i mean there's fans
and stuff but nobody
nobody's looking out for you yeah yeah
and the nice thing about spotify is they
want joe to
joe's podcast to succeed even more
that's
what joe talked about is that's the
difference between youtube and spotify
spotify wants to be the netflix of
podcasting
and they like what netflix does is they
they they don't want to control you in
any way but they want to create a
a platform where you can flourish even
when your interests are aligned
interests are alone so let me bring up
let me bring up something that uh
let's make a distinction because not all
companies who do this
are the same and you brought up youtube
and spotify but but to me youtube
is at least more like spotify than some
of these smaller uh the term is walled
garden right you've heard the term
walls garden okay so um i've been around
podcasting
so long now that i've seen rounds of
consolidation
over the years and they come in waves
and all of a sudden so you'll get uh and
i'm not going to mention any names but
but up until recently the consolidation
was happening with relatively
small firms compared to people like
spotify and the problem was is that by
deciding to
to consolidate your materials in a
walled garden
you are walling yourself off from
audience right
um so your choice is i'm going to accept
this amount of money from this company
but the loss is going to be a large
chunk of my audience and that's a
catch-22 because you're negotiating
power with that company is based on your
audience size
so signing up with them diminishes your
audience size you lose negotiating power
but when you get to the level of the
spotify to just
pick them out there's other players um
but you brought up spotify specifically
these are people who can potentially
potentially
enhance your audience over time and so
the risk to you is lower because if you
decide in a year or two
whatever the licensing agreement's term
is that you're done with them and you
want to leave
instead of how you would have been with
some of these smaller walled gardens
where you're walking away with a
fraction of the audience you walked in
with
you have the potential to walk out with
whatever you got in the original deal
plus a larger audience because their
algorithms and everything are designed
to push
uh people to your content if they think
you'd like
so it takes away some of the downside
risk
which which alleviates and if you can
write an agreement like joe rogan i mean
where you've protected your
your freedom to to put the content out
the way you want so and if some of the
downside risk is mitigated
and if you eliminate the problem of
trying to monetize and stay up with the
latest tech
then it might be worth it i you know i'm
scared of things like that but at the
same time i'm trying to not be an
idiot about it yes and i can be an idiot
about it
and when you've been doing it as
independently for as long as i have
the inertia of that uh has a force all
its own
but i'm i'm i'm inhibited
enough in what i'm trying to do on this
other end that it's opened me at least
to listening to people
yes um but um listen at the same time i
love my audience
and it sounds like a cliche but they're
literally the reason i'm
here so i want to make sure that
whatever i do
if i can is in keeping with a
relationship that i've developed with
these people over
15 years um but like you said no matter
what you do
you are go because see here's the thing
if you don't sign up with one of those
companies to make it easier for them to
get your stuff on this hand
they might yell at you for how difficult
it is because the new os
the new the new operating system just
updated and you just i can't get your
so either way you're opening yourself up
to ridicule at this point
all of that makes it easier to go well
if the right deal came along and they
weren't screwing me and they weren't
screwing my audience and blah blah
um you know i mean again in this
business when you're talking about
cutting edge technology that is
ever-changing and as you said a million
podcasts and growing
i think you have to try to maintain
flexibility and especially if they can
mitigate the downside risk
i think you have to i think you'd be an
idiot to not at least try
to stay up on the current trends and
look i'm watching joe
i'm going okay let's see how it goes for
joe yeah i mean if if
he's like ah this is terrible i'm
getting out of this you go okay those
people are right
you know so joe's put himself out as a
guinea pig and i and the rest of us
guinea pigs appreciate it as a huge as a
fan of your shows
and as a fan of netflix the people there
i think i can speak for like millions of
people
in hope that hardcore history comes to
netflix or if spotify becomes the
netflix of podcasting into spotify
there's something at its best that they
bring out the
you said artists so i can say it is they
bring out the best out of the artists
they they remove some of the headache
and somehow like they they put
at their best netflix for example is
able to
enforce and find the the beauty and the
power in the creations that you make
even better than you like they don't
interfere with the creations
but they somehow it's a it's a branding
thing probably too
interfering would be that would be a
no-go for me that's right absolutely
that can't help but that's why netflix
is masterful they
they seem to not interfere with the
talent as opposed to i could throw
other people under the bus like there's
a lot of places under the bus that could
be thrown
absolutely so i would love i know
there's probably people screaming yes
right now uh in terms of
hardcore history on netflix would be
awesome um
and i i don't love asking this question
but it's
asked probably the most popular question
that's unanswerable so let me try to ask
it in a way that you would actually
answer it
which is of course you said you don't
release shows very often
and uh the question is the requests and
the questions is what can you
tell dan to do one on the civil wars can
you tell dan to do one on the napoleon
bonaparte
can you tell them to do one you know
ever every topic and you've spoken to
this actually your answer about the
civil war is quite interesting
i didn't know you knew what my answer
but the civil war was that that you
don't you as a military historian you
enjoy
in particular when there is differences
in the armies
of contrast contrasts as with the civil
war which
like blew my mind when i heard you say
is you know it's
there's not an interesting a deep
intricate
contrast between the two opposings like
the roman civil wars which legionary
against legionary yeah
is and you've also said that you kind of
the shows you work on
are ones where you have some roots of
fundamental
understanding about that period and and
so
like when you work on a show it's
basically like pulling at those strings
further and
like refreshing your mind and learning
definitely
done the research wow these are like
words out of my mouth yeah you're right
so but is there something like
like shower thoughts on reddit uh is
there
some ideas that are like lingering in
your head about
possible future episodes is there things
that
whether you uh not committing to
anything but
uh whether you're gonna do it or not is
there something that's like
makes you think hmm that would be
interesting to uh
to pull at that thread a little bit oh
yeah i i we have things we keep in our
back pocket for later so
uh blueprint for armageddon the first
world war series we did that was in my
back pocket the whole time
and when the centennial of the war
happened it just seemed to be the likely
time to bring out what was
that was a hell of a series that's
probably one of my favorites my
rear end man i have to tell you
psychologically you know just
you know when you get to these i think
i'm guessing here i think it's 26 hours
all pieces together think about and and
we don't do scripts
it's improvised yeah so think about what
20 20
i had somebody write on twitter just
yesterday saying um
he said something like i'm not seeing
the dedication here you're only getting
2.5
shows out a year and i wanted to say man
you have no idea what
the only people who understand really
are other history podcasters
and even they don't generally do 26
hours you know that was a
two-year endeavor um as i said the first
show we ever did was like 15 minutes i
could crank out one of those a month
but when you're doing i mean the last
show we did on the fall of the roman
republic was
five and a half hours that's a book
right um
and it was part six or something so i
mean you just do the math
um and it felt like you were excited to
interrupt and on world war one
it felt like you were emotionally pulled
in
to it like it felt taxing i was gonna
say if that's a good thing though
because that you know and i think we
said during the show
that was the feeling that the people at
the time have and i think
at one point we said if this is starting
to seem gruesomely repetitive
now you know how the people at the time
felt
so in other words that had any sort of
inadvertently because when you improvise
the show some of these things are
inadvertent
but it had inadvertently created the
right climate
for having a sense of empathy with the
storyline
and to me that those are the
serendipitous moments that make this art
and not
uh some sort of paint by the numbers
kind of endeavor you know and
and that's to me that wouldn't have
happened had we scripted it out
so it's mostly you just bring the tools
of knowledge to the table and then in
large part
improvise like the actual wording i
always say we make it like they made
things like spinal tap and some of those
other things where
um the material so so i do have notes
about things like on page 427 of this
book you have this quote
so that i know aha i'm at the point
where i can drop that in
um and sometimes i'll write notes saying
here's where you left off yesterday so i
remember
um but in the improvisation you end up
throwing a lot out
and so um like like but it allows us to
go off on tangents like we'll try things
like i'll sit there and go
i wonder what this would sound like and
i'll spend two days
going down that road and then i'll
listen to him and go it doesn't work but
that's
you know like writers do this all the
time it's called killing your babies
right you got
can't you know get not but people go so
this guy goes i'm not seeing the
dedication he has no idea how many
things were thrown out
i did an hour and a half i had an hour
and a half into the current show
about two months ago and i listened to
it and i just went you know what it's
not right
boom out the window there goes six weeks
of work
yeah right but here's the problem you
trust you're sorry to interrupt do you
trust your judgment on that
no no uh but but here's here's the
here's the thing
um our show is a little different than
other people's uh joe rogan called it
evergreen
content in other words uh my political
show is like a car you buy and the
minute you drive it off the lot
it loses half its value right because
it's not current anymore
these shows are just as good or just as
bad uh five years from now as they are
when we do
although the standards on the internet
change so when i listen to my old shows
i cringe sometimes because the standards
are so much higher now
but when you're creating evergreen
content you have two audiences to worry
about
you have the audience that's waiting for
the next show and they've already heard
the other ones and they're impatient and
they're telling you on twitter where is
it
but you have show the show's also for
people five years from now who haven't
discovered it yet
and who don't care a wit for how long it
took because they're going to be able to
download the whole
and all they care about is quality and
so what i always tell new podcasters is
they always say i read all these things
it's very important you have a
release schedule well it's not more
important than putting out a good piece
of work
and the audience will forgive me
if it takes too long but it's really
good when you get it
they will not forgive me if i rush it to
get it out on time and it's a piece of
crap
so for us and this is why when you
brought up a spotify deal or anything
else
they can't interfere with this at all
because my my job here as far as i'm
concerned
is quality and everything else goes by
the wayside
because the only thing people care about
long term the only thing that gives you
longevity
is how good is it right how good is that
book if you read jrr tolkien's work
tomorrow
you don't care how long it took him to
write it all he cares how good is this
today
and that's what we try to think too and
i feel like if it's good if it's really
good
everything else falls into place and
takes care of itself um and although
sometimes to push back
sorry to interrupt i've done it to you a
thousand times so you can get me back
please
sometimes the deadline you know some of
the greatest like movies
and books have been you think about like
dostoyevsky i forget which one knows
from underground or something he needed
the money so he had to write it real
quick
sometimes the deadline creates
is powerful at taking a
creative mind of an artist and just like
slapping it around
to force some of the good stuff out now
the problem with history of course is
there's
there's different definitions of good um
that like
it's not just about what you talk about
which is the storytelling the richness
of the storytelling
and i'm sure you're you know again not
to compliment you too much but you're
one of the great storytellers of our
time
that that i'm sure if you put in a jail
cell and force
a like somebody point a gun at you you
could tell one hell of a good story
but you still need the facts of history
uh
or not necessarily the facts but you
know like
making sure you painting the right full
picture
not perfectly right that's what i meant
about the audience doesn't understand
what a history podcast is you can't just
riff and be wrong so
so let me let me both both oppose what
you just said and back up what you just
said excellent so i have a book that i
wrote right
and uh and in a book you have a hard
deadline right so harpercollins had a
hard deadline on that book
so when i released it i was mad because
i would have worked on it a lot longer
which is my style right
get it right but we had a chapter in
that book
entitled pandemic prologue question mark
and it was the book about the the part
about the black death and the
1918 flu and all that kind of stuff and
and i was just doing an interview with a
spanish journalist this morning who said
did you ever think how lucky you got on
that on that you know
and first of all lucky on a pandemic it
strikes you
but had i had my druthers
i would have kept that book working in
my study
for months more and the pandemic would
have happened
yes and that epis that would have looked
like a chapter i wrote after the fact
i would have to rewrite the whole thing
it would have been so that argues for
for what you said at the same time i
i would have spent months more working
on it because to me it didn't look the
way i wanted it to look yet
you know can you drop a hint of the
things that you're keeping on the
shelves
oh the alexander the great podcast i've
talked around the very
i i talked to somebody the other day
said do you know that the very first
word
in your very first podcast in the title
the very first thing that anybody ever
saw with hardcore history is that
is the word alexander and because the
show's entitled alexander versus hitler
i have talked around the career i've
done show after i talked about his
mother in one episode i talked about the
the the funeral games after his death
i've talked around this i've
specifically left this giant
alexandrian-sized hole in the middle
because we're going to do that show one
day and i'm going to lovingly enjoy
talking about this crazily interesting
figure of alexander the great so
that's one of the ones that's on the
back pocket list and what we try to do
is is um whenever this we're doing um
second world war in asia and the pacific
now i'm on part five
whenever the heck we finish this the
tendency is to then pick a very
different period because
we've had it and the audience has had it
um so it's time
so um i will eventually get to the
alexander saga
what about just one last kind of little
part of this
is uh what about the other half of that
first 10-minute
15-minute episode which is so you've
done
quite a bit about the world war you've
done quite a bit about germany
will you ever think about doing hitler
the man
it's funny because uh i talked earlier
about how i don't like to go back to the
old shows because our standards have
changed so much well a long time ago
one of my standards for not getting
five hour podcasts done or or not
getting too deeply into them
was to flit around the interesting
points we didn't realize we were going
to get an audience that wanted the
actual
history we thought we could just go with
assume the audience knew the details and
just talk about the weird stuff that
only makes up one part of the show now
so we did a show called nazi tidbits and
it was just
little things about you know it's
totally out of date now like you know
you can still buy them but they're out
of date
um where we dealt a little with it uh
you know it would be interesting but
i'll give you another example i mean
history is not
stagnant as you know uh and we had
talked about stalin
earlier and uh ghost of the offspring
was done years ago and people will write
me from russia now and say well your
portrayal of stalin
is totally out of uh out of uh uh it's
it's
outdated because there's all this new
stuff from the former soviet union
and you do you turn around and you go
okay um they're right
and so when you talk about hitler
it's very interesting to think about how
i would do a hitler show today versus
how i did one
10 years ago um and you would think well
what's new i mean it happened so long
but there's lots of new stuff and
there's lots of new scholarship and
and so um yeah i would think that would
be an interesting one to do someday
uh i i haven't thought about that that's
not in the back pocket
but uh but yeah that'd be interesting i
have a disproportionate amount of power
because
i trapped you somehow in the room and
and thereby
during a pandemic so like my
hope will be stuck in your head but
after alexander the great which would be
an amazing uh podcast i
i hope you do cons give a return to
hitler
the rise and fall of the third reich
which
to me uh i i have a contemporary book
basically
yeah yeah and i exactly it's by a person
who was there
shira yeah i i really
loved that study of the man of hitler
and i would love to hear your
study of certain aspects of it perhaps
even an episode that's like more focused
on a very particular period
i just feel like you can uh tell a story
that it's funny hitler is one of the
most studied people and i still feel
like this
all the stories or most of the stories
haven't been told oh and there's listen
i've got
three books at home i'm on all the
publishers lists now and they just
young hitler there's this hitler there's
that i mean i've been reading these
books and i've read about hitler i read
the rise and fall of the third reich my
mother thought i needed to go to a
psychologist
because i read it when i was six and she
said there's something wrong with the
boy
and but but um but she was right but she
was absolutely right
but uh but you would think that that
something like that
is pretty established fact and yet
there's new stuff coming out all the
time and needless to say
uh germany's been investigating this guy
forever and sometimes it takes years to
get the translations
i took five years of german in school i
can't read
any of it so um so i mean and
and he is when you talk about
fascinating figures he's so
the whole thing is so twistedly weird um
there was a
it came out a couple years ago somebody
found a tape of him
talking to uh gender i want to say it
was general um
uh the finnish general manaheim right um
and and he's just in a very
normal conversation of the sort we're
having now and you know the hitler tapes
when you hear
normally he's ranting and raving but
this was a very sedate and i wish i'd
understood the german well enough to
really get a feel because i was reading
uh what germans said they said wow you
can really hear
the southern accent you know little
things that only a a native speaker
would hear
and i remember thinking this is such a
different side of this twisted character
and you would think you would always
you would think that this was
information that was out in in in in the
rise and fall of the third ranking but
it wasn't
and so this this this is uh goes along
with that stuff about new stuff coming
out all the time alexander new stuff
coming out all the time
really well at least interpretations
rather than factual data and those color
your
those give depth to your understanding
yes you and you want that because
the historiography people people love
that and that was a byproduct of my
lack of credentials where we thought
we're going to bring in
um the historians we call them audio
footnotes
right a way for me to say listen i'm not
a historian but i'll quote this guy who
is so you can trust him
but then we would quote other people who
had different views and people didn't
realize that that you know if they're
not history majors
that historians don't always agree on
this stuff and that they have
disagreements and they
loved that so so i i love the fact that
there's more stuff out there because it
allows us to then bring in
um other points of view and sort of
maybe three-dimensionalize or flesh out
the story a little bit more two last
questions one really simple one
absurdly ridiculous and perhaps also
simple
first who is ben and is he real
i don't even know what you're talking
about very well
how's that for an answer it's like
asking me is harvey the white rabbit
reel i don't know
there's carrots all around the
production room but i don't know what
that means
well a lot of people demanded that i
prove
i somehow figure out a way to prove the
existence if i said he was real people
would say
no he's not and if i said he was if he
wasn't real they would say yes he is so
it's a santa claus easter bunny kind of
vibe there
yeah i mean what is real anyway that's
exactly what i told him if it exists
okay the most absurd question i'm very
sorry
very excited but then again i'm not what
what's the meaning of it all you
you study history
of human history
have you been able to make sense of why
the hell we're here on this
spinning rock does any of it even make
sense what's the meaning
of life what i look at
sometimes that i find interesting is
certain consistencies that we have over
time
uh history doesn't repeat but it has a a
constant and the constant is us
now we change i mentioned earlier the
the
wickedly weird time we live in with what
social media is doing to us as guinea
pigs and that's a new element
but we're still people who are motivated
by
love hate greed envy sex i mean all
these things that would have connected
us with the ancients right
that's the part that always makes
history sound like it rhymes
you know and when you put
the constant the human element and you
mix it with
systems that are similar so one of the
reasons that the ancient roman republic
is something that people
point to all the time um as a as
something that seems like we're
repeating history is because you have
the two con
you have humans just like you had then
and you have a system that resembles
the one we have here so you throw the
constant in with a system that is
somewhat similar
and you begin to see things that look
like they rhyme a little
um so for me i'm always trying to figure
out more about
us and when you show us in uh
500 years ago in asia and 800 years ago
in africa and you look at all these
different places that you put
the guinea pig in and you watch how the
guinea pig responds to the different
stimuli
and challenges i feel like it helps me
flesh out a little bit more who we are
in the long
timeline not who we are today
specifically but who we've always been
um it's a personal quest it's not meant
to educate anybody else it's it's
something that fascinates me
do you think there's uh in that common
humanity throughout history the
of the guinea pig is there a why
underneath it all
or is it somehow like it feels like it's
an experiment of some sort
oh now you're into elon musk and i
talked about this the simulation thing
right nick bostrom's sure
yeah the idea that there's some some kid
and we're the equivalent of an alien's
ant farm
you know and we hope he doesn't throw a
tarantula in just to see what happens um
i think the whys elude us
and i think that what makes philosophy
and religion
and those sorts of things so interesting
is that they grapple with
the whys um but i'm not
wise enough to to uh
propose a theory myself but i'm
interested enough to read all the other
ones out there
so um i i let's put it this way i don't
think there's any definitive why that's
been agreed upon but the various
theories are fascinating
yeah whatever it is whoever the kid is
that created this thing
the the ant farm kind of interesting
it's so far a little bit a little bit
twisted and perverted and sadistic
that's what makes it fun i think um but
then again that's the russian
perspective
i was just gonna say
it is the russian perspective
a little bit of what makes the russians
so russian history one day i'll do some
russian history i took it to college
that's the ant farm baby that's an ant
farm with a very
very frustrated young uh uh
teenage alien kid dan
i can't say i've already complimented
you way too much i'm a huge fan
this has been an incredible conversation
it's a huge gift
i your your gift of humanity i hope you
let me cut you off and just say you've
done a wonderful job this has been fun
for me
the questions and more importantly the
questions can come from anybody
the counter statements your responses
have been wonderful you made this a very
fun intellectual discussion for me thank
you well let me have the last word and
say
i agree with elon and despite the doom
caster
say that i think we've concluded
definitively and you don't get a chance
to respond that
love is in fact the answer and the way
forward
so thanks so much dan thank you for
having me
thanks for listening to this
conversation with dan carlin and thank
you to our sponsors
athletic greens the all-in-one drink
that i start
every day with to cover all my
nutritional bases
simply safe a home security company i
use to monitor and protect my apartment
magic spoon low-carb keto friendly
cereal that i think is delicious
and finally cash app the app i used to
send money to friends
for food and drinks please check out
these sponsors in the description
to get a discount and to support this
podcast
if you enjoy this thing subscribe on
youtube review it with five stars and
upper podcast
follow on spotify support on patreon or
connect with me on twitter
alex friedman and now let me leave you
with some words
from dan carlin wisdom
requires a flexible mind
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time
you